the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
it was an exciting day at the Cairns Cup
in Saint Louis a day that looked to be
drifting off into a snoozefest quickly
erupted with unexpected outcomes well
later Irina Crush was caught napping in
what turned into a nightmare loss for
her and a dream come true for her
opponent a sleeping giant has been
awakened as the lowest rated player
undefeated Anna zatonski is proving to
be a formidable Foe for her competition
dispatching Alexandra castenyuk to steal
clear first the favorites are wounded
how will they respond to the pressure
day five of fiery chess coming up next
[Music]
thank you
hello everyone welcome back to round
five of the Karen's cup it's the day
before the rest day the players are
starting to arrive let's go in the
studio and get this party started
welcome to Saint Louis the home of Chess
in America and the third edition of the
Karens cup one of the richest women's
tournaments in chess we come to your
life from the San Luis chess club
foreign
[Music]
good morning and welcome everyone thank
you for joining us I'm International
Master nazify kids and I'm here with my
brilliant co-host yesterday one
wow
unfortunately a very very impactful day
we have some Dreadful news to share with
you our defending Champion
humpicanero has withdrawn from the
tournament due to illness Tony Rich the
executive director of the St Louis chess
club is with Almera to explain how this
will impact our tournament over to you
El Mira
oh yes hello yes sir hello Nazi I'm
joined in the studio by Tonya Rich the
executive director of the San Luis chess
club Tonya this is a very unusual
situation please tell us how does it
impact the tournament sure you know it's
unfortunate when any player has to
withdraw from an event and as Yasser
mentioned due to illness humpy notified
us last night that she had to withdraw
from the 2023 Cairns cup now the fide
regulations are pretty clear on events
especially around Robin events when a
player withdraws the regulations state
that if a player withdraws before the
halfway point and since this was around
four out of nine it was before the
halfway point of the tournament in cases
where a player withdraws before that
halfway point all of their previous
results are annulled and all of their
future opponents get a rest day instead
of playing them on the day they would
have played them so essentially it turns
this into a tournament of nine players
instead of a tournament of 10 players
okay thank you Tony this was a very
clear explanation and yes sir would you
be so kind to explain us how does it
affect the standings absolutely thank
you Tony thank you Almera indeed it's
very very impactful on the standings
because just around previously
uh Alexandra was in first place not any
longer and Nessie do the honors let's
take a look at standings after round
four Anna satonski is still in the lead
in solid with three points out of four
right and Sharon in second place are
four players Elizabeth pets Bella Hotel
Nashville
and Irina crush and again Alexandra
drops down because a point essentially
was taken away from her as um well
because of homepiece withdrawal and tell
us about the new format now that is no
longer 10 round 10 player around Robin
right now we have a nine play around
robin tournament Players are not allowed
to offer any draws and the time control
is classical 90 minutes for first 40
moves 30 minutes rest of the game and 30
second increment from move one and our
schedule
players will play a total of nine rounds
today they'll be playing round five and
tomorrow they have a rest day right and
then it's a Sprint to the finish with
the four remaining games playoffs
nothing very nice Almera it's not
exactly bonjour but we do have a clear
leader leading by a point Anna zatonski
yes let's have a look at Anna zetonski's
tournament trajectory how did she get
here I think that in the first round we
we will have the graphics for you she
Drew against Nana jagni the one of the
top players in the world in the second
round she defeated Bella Hotel Nashville
with black pieces then she Drew against
Elizabeth pets and yesterday and I'm not
afraid of this of using this world she
completely outplayed the former world
champion Alexandre castino who was
leading the tournament after the round
three so another scored three points out
of four and let's look at the way ahead
in the round five she is playing against
Harry cadrana Valley and around six
she's going to face the young star from
Azerbaijan gunai mamadada and then in
around seven she will play against uh
John Saya abdumalik she has I think that
she's in a very good position to win
this tournament and I wanted to say that
Anna zetovski is such a wonderful
ambassador of the women's chess and of
the US chess I wanted to remind you that
her big rating was 25 37 it's a warping
25-37 and I'm so happy because she
represents Our Generation so so tired of
all these youngsters winning the
tournament so go Anna yes sir what do
you think should we make new picks for
the tournament we may very well have to
with humpy's withdrawal it's so
impactful absolutely and uh
as a four-time U.S Champion uh well
she's she's just a wonderful wonderful
competitor and I'm sure
I don't know I don't know we can that
seems a little bit unfair but uh yeah
well now it's only going to be four
rounds of play in four games of play
please now if you do the parent do do
the honors and the pairings for this
round five what can our viewers expect
let's take a look
today our leader Anna zatonski is
playing harika Journal Valley I'll be
your Marquee matchup jeans I Abdul Malik
will face Alexandra costanuk
Irina Crush playing Elizabeth pets
another Marquee matchup as the players
tied for second and the two Georgians
will face each other today Nana and Ella
Hotel Nashville exactly a lot of fears
play ahead fighting what are they
fighting for and there's a buy round for
gunai mamadan yes and the Buy Round yes
players are fighting for a lot of money
there is total of hundred and eighty
thousand dollars in prizes right and the
first place winner is going to win forty
five thousand dollars second place
thirty five thousand third twenty five
thousand prizes all the way down uh for
all competitors including Humpty who
steps out of the tournament once again
citing illness as we go to the World
Chess Hall of Fame I think we're
actually going to have a special bell
ringer today that's on often times get a
chance to step out into the Limelight is
my friend coaster kavalski he'll be
ringing the bell and he writes the recap
Arc calls for the Saint Louis chess club
exactly just to after the round he's
very very
I want to say punctual and getting
the information out who did what and
there he is
as players are ready to begin their
round
I must say it I it's so impactful when
somebody withdraws I mean obviously
Magnus withdrawn from the singville cup
that's rather Unforgettable a defending
Champion uh Hopi I'm sure she's just
distraught uh herself having to withdraw
but life goes on I mean now it's a new
round you can't lose focus tomorrow is
the rest day everybody's going to put
their their maximum efforts exactly now
let's focus on this uh matchup this is
our key matchup as Anna with the white
pieces against harika say she won both
games with the black pieces
Anna has yes
counter-attack
counter attack the French defense you're
right and Almera uh tell us what what
you expect out of this key matchup
uh this is a very important game for
Anna because I think that harika is a
very solid player so she will seize the
initiative the initiative well when
given a chance so I think that Anna will
play D4 today
and that she will not take any risks
with white pieces
d2d4
and for harika what would you expect
ah well it's not that easy hair opening
repertoire is quite wide so she the
spectrum of the openings that she plays
is
we're really very large
International Master Costa kavutsky like
I said he writes articles for San Luis
chess club analyzes the games and he
also runs the chess Dodger Channel there
you have it
rings the bell that looks like fun yeah
it does right that's a very large
remind Their audience and you see I'm
the Oracle finally
that some of the flares still have four
rounds ahead of them but some only have
three rounds ahead of them so this
should be taken into account of course
you mean after this game after this
round is over yeah some players will
have a buy uh
and an extra free round uh obviously so
uh D4 D5 C4 E6 and uh let me just see my
boards are updating but uh all right uh
Anna
she plays a Queen's Gambit declined uh
as black herself but we know that for
peculiar reasons she likes to think over
moves three four five even though she's
incredibly well versed in this specific
position uh she still likes to take her
time Knight C3 now in that game uh where
C7 C6
Irena crashed noneza played c64
extremely sharp game exactly and
peculiar move
age six age six like just a second let
me just uh I'm not familiar with this
move at all H seven H I've seen it
Oxford Knight F6 but not right away
I wonder if there's a difference in this
move order well in the lines where we
play E4 where there's a Pawn on C6 it's
actually more useful for example if we
just put this variation on the board not
to weaken
the D6 Square so Bishop check let's just
go here Queen takes Bishop takes Queen
takes Bishop E7 when the pawn is on C6
there's a nasty threat of Queen D sixth
that you have to deal with with the pawn
still on C7 that
it's not a problem but H7 H6 Almera
um I look at scans at this move but I
see that it's been played before it's
been played several times before and
especially during the past few years and
I think that a lot of these games were
played online because we live in an area
where uh Grandmasters have so many
opportunities to try their opening
repair online so they can make mistakes
and this move H6 was played by Magnus
Carlsen several times and I think that
you need to to find a variation where it
will be useful in the Queen's Gambit so
I think that in many variations where
white will play Bishop G5 you know this
move is no longer possible so let's see
at this structure so you will play
Knight F3 I've seen a few games played
by timora Jabba giri this is a very
sorry corrupt we made a slight mistake
so in Anna harika's game she played
Knight F6 apparently we have the exact
same opening in the game Irina Crush
Elizabeth hats
no I think it was my fault I I led us
astray I thought we were citing Anna's
game and we saw H6 it was actually
Elizabeth game but continue because H6
works for the other very yeah this
should be true for both games I think
wow first of all you know black was
we're using the move A6 I think this is
how the theory evolves they tried to
move A6 and then they said okay
yeah look at the two boards one has a
knight on F6 one has the pawn on H six
that's Elizabeth page well
yeah just to confuse us all well one is
the more classical opening and here you
have a very creative approach so H6 923
uh White is not trying to review the
opening strategy immediately so Knight
F3 is a very useful move here Knight F6
of course and so uh
C takes defies this defines the
structure immediately
it's a Carlsbad structure so you go for
uh you have the pound minority here
attack when pound minority attack later
so where do you put your Bishop here if
you no longer have a this G5 Square
because very often like in the variation
without H6 like if Knight F6 is played
if you place it takes D5 C takes D5 you
play Bishop G5 I would say this is a
very original idea which does not allow
you to put your Bishop on G5 and of
course white plays Bishop F4 here so I
think one of the most interesting idea
ideas here is that after H6 and Bishop
before you can play Bishop D6
immediately and exchange these dark
Square Bishops so after Bishop D6 Queen
D6 you will have the usual structure
white will play E3
so you can Castle you can play Bishop D3
and you there are a few moves possible
Bishop G4 with a very complicated play
and C6 it's slightly better for white
but I think this is the the position
that Elizabeth is aiming for
and in their head-to-head matchups uh
there's only a single game I wouldn't
have guessed that at all this cannot be
true I mean really rather shocking right
when you think of all the olympiads and
these two top ladies they've only met
Once In classical chess wow must have
been in the previous Karen's cup then
too probably right okay H7 H6 now when I
when I see that move by the way it's a
move I look at a scans and what I mean
by that is we are really trained from
the very opening from from from the very
first move it's all about play in the
center we try to control these 16
squares from start literally to finish
but especially from the start so
something some opening move that doesn't
impact the center we kind of say well
what are you actually doing the move age
7h6 does not impact the center and you
almost look at that move and you say oh
I can refute it right you are going to
have a very very bad position
after this move and normally speaking
you you try to blast open the center
anything that's a Gambit starts to
become very very attractive so you you
start to think how can I play for E4 and
do it right away so let's say an
immediate E4 and we finally we do have a
move Bishop F4 by Arena an immediate E4
maybe is not the best idea so especially
without preparation exactly so Knight F3
Knight F6 Queen C2
so this is a kind of a way of saying
okay I want you to move your Bishop so
that when I play E4 I'm not really
afraid of Bishop B4 check and I would be
very very happy if you captured my Pawn
because then I get you know the full
control of the center and I get to
punish H6 if black were to play Bishop
B4 here it transposes to nimso with
Queen c2d5 but there is this H6 move
that is not necessarily an useful move
exactly we did see that Arena did Play
Bishop F4 without first capturing and
defining the center as Amira was saying
the Carlsbad I like the move Bishop F4
it doesn't seek to
refute uh Black's Play It's just
basically saying hey I'm I'm developing
my pieces what exactly are you doing
with the move H7 H6
if we jump
we jump Georgian man Ager
symmetrical position I was about to say
you you talked you had asked me in a
previous broadcast did I like the double
fee and Shadow well I'd like to show you
two players who do like the double fee
and Shadow uh yeah a symmetrical
position uh just one thing to say about
this particular opening
I am not let me emphasize I am not a
friend of the orangutan uh one b2b4
however check this out Knight F3 Knight
F6 C4 G6
here I actually think the orangutan is
actually uh a very useful idea the idea
is after B4 Bishop G7 uh Bishop B2
you you get a specific your your
narrowing uh Black's choices here black
doesn't as in the game get to play the
symmetrical uh move b2b4 is a good way
of preventing the symmetry which now
appears and
well okay
um that it was this game yeah yeah this
game will be defined by who is the first
to play either D4 or D5 and we'll keep
an eye on that one just want to go back
to the game of Anna for a moment because
we did have in her game the very
conventional Knight F6 Bishop G5 and
they're playing Queen's Gambit
um main lines of Queensland main lines
exactly and then finally in our fourth
oh I was about to say we went from
opening to end game because yeah I think
wasn't this the game of humpy and uh
harika oh yeah yes earlier in the
tournament yeah
um well again a very theoretical dispute
but uh we have seen
um this line of play earlier in the
tournament it leads to a draw if black
plays it very very accurately
and uh Elmira what uh what has caught
your eye
so I just wanted to show you
how
white should proceed were black at least
they should play Rook B8 of course in
this position how did we get this
position in in the previous game between
hurricane and hampi coneros so
white Place rugby one so Queen B1 that's
how we actually get this end game
so which is very important a lot of top
games of course so Rook d8
here and Bishop F3
which was played in the game that you
mentioned before with lisso against
Magnus Carlson so
um Bishop A6
oh sorry not this was not Bishop B6 it
was me uh King f8 first then uh Rook B3
Bishop A6
where this is once again this is the
line that I analyzed myself yes because
I'm trying to improve every time I'm
looking at this position I'm trying to
improve on this game so
let me see what happened actually I
think rugby eight yes Rook B8 rookie
eight that was the line right and then
H4 is Bishop B6
and then once in with a very important
moment the key moment is this in this
game that you have to play Bishop B2 and
not something like rookie 5 because
after rookie five let's say this end
game is very unpleasant because you will
have a very passive Rook if you will
play rookie seven so this game is
leading his head in for a draw
all right uh thank you for that uh yeah
that I mean it's
how do I put it it it's like if you
don't want to fight with white and you
don't want to give your opponent any
chances it's a it's a the scotch is a
decent way of neutralizing uh Black's
counter play counter chances you need to
learn how to do that because we're not
exactly
don't do that don't do that I did want
to say
um I caught up in the game Irina and
Elizabeth were already in New Territory
there's only three games in the database
after Bishop D6 wow Bishop D6 I can
imagine Bishop G3
inviting the trade but only on White's
terms
funnily enough in the game between uh
country yeah and yes exactly from
yesterday white went for this type of
structure but I would imagine Bishop G3
again as piring to play E2 E4 and trying
to prove that maybe the pawn on H6 is
witness place I think
I think approach is similar
alerts yesterday against Irena just take
a ring out of preparation and not get a
typical classical position because I
realized so much knowledge yes and yeah
just simply third move H6 already new
type of position well only three games
after Bishop D6 well Bishop G3 I just
wanted to say that yesterday we were a
little bit confounded and it goes to
show that even very experienced
Grandmasters like myself sometimes get
it completely wrong so what had happened
was uh one of the players
didn't make the time control but the
clock reset as if the time control had
been made right right and she didn't
press a clock she overstepped the the
time control and the clocks are
purposely made to do that
in my time we often we'd start a
player's clock and for some reason it
wouldn't tick and we'd press it and
press it again well the clocks of today
are counting the moves so in this
particular dgt digital game timer clock
the idea is that as soon as a player's
flag Falls or time control is made it's
updated but the clock also shows whose
flag fell first right so it's very nice
it shows how many moves have been made
exactly moves to so yes I received an
email yesterday from the Arbiter Chris
bird explain that even though 30 minutes
was added and they haven't reached the
time control it still showed that white
flagged precise there was a flag little
flag on the clock and by the way deputy
Arbiter Chris bird because uh Judith is
the chief Arbiter Bishop G3 by Arena
crash now uh tell me about arena for a
moment she had an enormous setback uh
yesterday she was tied for first she
went in in this game against Bella Bella
made this intuitive Pawn sacrifice on
the queen side distracted her pieces and
launched this huge King side attack that
eventually brought her Victory but
somewhere in between that Victory
um Arena could have won she was in time
trouble she missed her chance
a loss impacts us all but a loss where
you could have won
ooh tell us about how she might be
feeling it's definitely difficult to
recover from that yeah but if we look at
yesterday's games there was a crazy
fight it it really was it could have
gone either way and Irina defended
extremely well and there was only one
moment where she was winning but she had
30 seconds on the clock so she I don't
think she should feel too bad about
missing it because in 30 seconds in a
complicated position finding the only
accurate movie is extremely difficult
yeah the play was against her if you
will I mean she was mainly on the black
back foot with the peace sacrifice that
Bella made could have rebounded but like
you say it was only 30 seconds very hard
to hard to find that chemo Irina is
extremely experienced player so I don't
think she's thinking about yesterday's
game no no but uh to put that loss and
say okay it didn't happen new game very
very hard right
of course yeah very hard uh I saw that
arena is actually thinking in this
position and I was thinking to myself
well Bishop G3 is so
standard you you you you start to think
what could possibly be an alternative
uh let me uh ask you is this completely
ridiculous Knight H3 I mean you're not
gonna take and invite my knight to uh
but let's say I just developed like
Knight F6 okay very nice and let's say I
in turn are you happy with them
kind of reminds me some Dutch lines yes
where white does develop an I don't have
three and then sorry H3 and goes to F4
D3 and E5 right in this particular case
when you say Dutch the pawn would be on
F5 and not on F7 but I'm just trying to
get into uh Arena's thought processes
there by the way she she find another
alternative to Bishop G3 as well as
Knight H3 she ended up taking maybe
Knight H3 isn't as bad as it looks
I've been like crickets around here uh
Bishop
D6 Bishop one of the things that uh I'm
very very reluctant is help my opponent
develop their pieces Bishop takes D6 is
a move I personally would have resisted
uh there must be a reason a very
specific reason again that Arena would
do such a thing she just played E4 and
that is if she wants to play the move E2
E4 so in this particular case remember
it was that Bishop B4 check that was
bothering us without the dark Square
Bishop she is inviting a queen trade and
doubtlessly she's thinking well in this
ending I have more space better
development and uh H7 H6 is a waste to
move is that the was was that how do you
say computer or approved by the Oracle
Elmira if this is a prophecy you wanted
to say let's see I wanted to assure you
that after Bishop D6 Queen D6 if not E4
I try to understand the position a
little bit and what if white would go
for another positional
uh move C5 because I think it would have
Justified the move Bishop D6 Queen D6 C5
maybe Queen is seven then you simply
play Knight F3 Knight F6 is three
castle and I was thinking that here you
could play B4 and you have a very nice
position like it doesn't give me like
blacks has still to deal with the bishop
on C8 right and reminds some types of
the
um slav positions you know that you
might get but if you play C6 here uh so
I think that white has a slight
Advantage here but which will last so a
long lasting Advantage but here after E4
what I didn't like that the dark Square
Bishops were exchanged so I think that
after d takes C4 Knight E4 Queen B4
a very natural move you will have to
play Queen Z2 and what's
I don't like is that here you would have
to take with the King most probably
because Knight D2 well this was this is
not a very good Square for the night
first of all because you play D4 you
took an E4 you exchanged Twins and and
after Knight CS6 you know I don't think
that black has any problem here because
I will develop and I will play B6 Bishop
B7 and this is a very fine position for
black and what about I like King on D2
uh King takes D2 in that variation yes
and your king marches towards the C3
Square here I think B6 is a very nice
move because you need to develop your
Bishop
um
rookie one and rookie one yeah just uh
I don't this is of course is already a
very new position even for the computer
so he has to understand this uh so maybe
now you can no longer play negative six
maybe Knight E7 would be a more
interesting Square yeah it didn't fall
from my trap I wanted you to play Knight
F6 so I could capture and play D5 yes it
may be early in the afternoon but I was
still Pond hunting that was of course
White's idea but right here 97 yes I
avoid all
of traps in this position and how should
you develop here Knight F3 is a very
natural move and I wanted to Castle
but maybe here you have this D5 move
I think so yes yes let's calculate and
then Knight F6 check oh Knight F6
detects of six Rook is seven
complications yes yeah in the middle
game maybe maybe favorable compensation
uh intriguing
and with the reshuffle once again uh our
defending Champion has withdrawn and
with the new standings and I see we have
a soul leader Anna satonski three points
and sharing second or four players
Elizabeth pets Bella hotanashvili kunai
mamazada and Irina crush and with one
and a half Point Alexandra costing you
Harry cadrona Valley and Nana technite I
think they all already played koneru
right and the last place at the moment
Josiah up to Malik exactly and Anna is
playing harika who is currently tied for
okay uh intriguing Arena Bishop takes uh
D6 oh excuse me let me just do that
again Bishop takes D6 Queen takes D6 I
believe E4 is on the is D takes E4 yes
Knight takes C4 Knight takes E4
definitely expecting Queen before yeah I
queen F4 looks uh completely wrong A
Move by Queen F4 attacking Knight on e4
would just invite Queen F3 and again
what I was saying I'm very very
reluctant to help my opponent develop
their pieces uh with Queen F4 Queen
takes after Queen B4 checked Queen D2
and I was a little bit surprised that
the computer felt that um
oh I think it was actually B6 that uh
Almera was fine I was a little surprised
that uh the the the computer felt that
after this position 97 white wasn't a
smidge better computer said no no no
it's absolutely absolutely even
um maybe if that is true the move H7 H6
will
yeah exactly if you can get an easy
equality with the black pieces well I
think the main idea of H6 is just to
avoid all those Queens can be declined
positions with Bishop G5 yep so H7 H6
wow so how important is the surprise
value in the modern chess because
players they've spent hours and hours
repeating the variations that they've
already analyzed and as Alexander
explained in the interview sometimes
even the variations that the their
opponents have not played yet so
um probably irenae is facing the the
opening idea which she didn't analyze at
home exactly again I'm sitting there at
the chess board I'm seeing H7 H6 more or
less for the first time or second or
third time and I'm thinking to myself
well how would I refute it probably I
think that it's critical to get the move
E2 E4 going maybe it's time to try to
play a Catalan G2 G3 aspiring for E
Bishop G2 and E4 and hoping to prove
that the move H7 H6 is a wasted Tempo
but that's water under the bridge
because what we have instead I keep
doing that it doesn't want to update
my ward pardon me where are we here we
are uh finally we get the updates of
every game yes exactly uh we'll walk
around the arena Queen takes D2 again
I'm expecting Arena will recapture where
they're King Knight takes D2
as you were saying Amira what's the
night doing on D2 it's not the most
fortunate square and this move B7 B6
let's see seems like the way to go the
bishop is not going uh this direction so
B7 B6 V and shadowing just one other
look B7 B6 Bishop uh E2 Bishop B7 Bishop
F3 with the threat of a discovered check
guessing night would come out
and
yeah it's I don't see any normal
problems for black it's not that great I
must admit the bishop on F3 might look
attractive but all that's really trying
to do is neutralize this bishop Amira
over to you any uh where's the action
show me the action
well maybe we should step in and play
I'll assure you the action let's have a
look because I I think that this game
will be over in a few moves
D4 so she defined the structure first so
after D4
um one of the ideas is sometimes to take
with the queen and if the opponent I
don't know why you should if the
opponent allows you to after D6 you can
always transfer your queen to H4 so it's
uh it's a very interesting position some
games were played already on the top
level and so well you're looking on the
on your opponent's Kings and so after
Knight bd7
my C3 this might be the position also
that Nana is aiming for
but you could also take here
with the Knight
which is probably less usual because you
will simply exchange the light Square
bishop and after D5 black equalizes
quite comfortably so I think Queen D4 is
to be expected here absolutely and there
are lifetime Head to Head matchups these
two top Georgian ladies have played each
other a lot 20 to times
a big Edge there to Nana looking at our
Marquee matchup between Anna and harika
I'm a little bit surprised by herika's
opening choice because essentially
Queen's Gambit declined everybody
understands Queen Gambit declined E2 E3
H7 H6 uh Bishop
um
H4 so there are a couple of schools of
thought here one school of thought is
that you Castle
oops excuse me why is that uh yeah you
Castle Knight F3 and then you say to
yourself well how am I developing my
queen side oh I know you play B 7 B6 uh
let's say Rook C1 just as a conventional
move Bishop B7 and you look to develop
your Bishop along this open diagonal
especially if you're allowed to play D5
takes E4 then I think pretty often here
black plays Knight E4 and exchanges
black Square Bishop indeed and 94 as
well as Knight D7 and C5 very very
conventional play there are many many
many games which continue in this
fashion takes take Stakes you play the
move b2b4 because you want to hold up uh
the move C7 C5 but what you can see here
is that in this particular line of play
Black uh
uh placed for the open diagonal what
harika did
and also another line of play is black
play C7 C5 yeah kind of a tarash if you
will uh
uh way of play uh harika didn't do this
she played Bishop E7 and then C7 C6 and
this isn't really considered that great
uh way of playing you just mentioned
that one of the the ways of freeing your
position is to play the move Knight E4
and I was always taught that after Queen
C2 castles uh black ends up in a more
passive position than you deserve the
the opening shouldn't give you such a
passive position sorry would you cast
along here for white I would definitely
think about it because this is like one
of those games where yeah I kind of feel
like black has
the move C7 C6 kind of like the H6 I
don't really feel that that necessarily
fits in the ischemia development another
thing I start to think about as well is
just what will Black's next move be like
if I Castle I can imagine I give you the
idea of do you take C4 and B5 so if I
make a waiting move and say black needs
to still finish development so B6 Bishop
B7 would be my exactly and then it's
sort of like well if your Pawn was on C7
your Bishop would already be on B7 and
then you might be be playing for C5
important Tempo the black spend on
playing C6 exactly or maybe harika wants
to play Queen A5 like a like a a
Cambridge Spring before Castle after
Queen C2 maybe maybe she'll Supply Queen
A5 like a Cambridge Sprint then it's
also surprising because she already has
Bishop on E7 correct that's in Queen A5
lines Bishop usually goes to B4 exactly
and it's like combined into different
designs and sometimes when you make that
combination of the two different lines
you end up with the disadvantage that
each of them is without any of the real
advantages something like Knight D2 and
it's sort of like well why did I put my
Bishop on E7 my queen on A5 what am I
trying to pursue uh we'll keep an eye on
that because for for Anna again this is
that these positions is defined her
career she's been playing Queens Gambit
declines both sides for many many years
so she's going to be familiar with the
nuances of this position Amira jump in
yes I wanted to unveil the mystery of
this position for you this variation has
become very popular lately especially
really because Magnus Carlson was using
this setup and I also I I found it
extremely strange at the beginning but
then I've looked at a few games and
let's see how the game could continue
Bishop D3 is a very natural move so
Castle
so White Castles once again so here D
takes C4
Bishop C4 B5
Bishop G3 Bishop B7 here white has a few
Alternatives you can play Rook C1
has happened also in the game between
anus Gary and Magnus Carlsen so or you
can play A3 like timura job of plate so
I really think that this is harika's
preparation so this is the critical
position for white and I think that's
when they will reach this position Anna
will spend some time quite some time
here in order to to make the next move
right so oh um yeah well a kind of a
combination of the Murano and well
something very modern but we have a
tweet let's see what we've got uh
race incoming this is from YouTube what
goes through your mind when you've
realized they walked into your
opponent's preparation and it started
from yesterday oh yes well absolutely in
the good old days when you had an
enormous amount of time like two and a
half hours for your first 40 moves and
Then followed by a a an adjournment if
you will whenever we got surprised the
idea was to stop and to think 20 30
minutes
before responding like to try to really
get the Zen and the understanding of the
position so Novelties you would see the
players go into a deep freeze today you
don't have that luxury you really have
to be familiar with it so you're not
completely thrown off track
preparation yeah one of the one of the I
want to say tragedies of my career I
don't I think that's an overstatement
but oftentimes a lot of the ideas that I
had prepared for my opponents somebody
else got to show first I was like no no
no that was my preparation and you know
other players you know winning novelty
of the year and stuff like that and I
remember actually one of my opponents
Beulah Sachs had walked right into my
preparation in a perk defense I
completely rewrote the theory of this
particular line and
uh White has a force uh Perpetual in the
position if he wants and Eula thought
for a whole hour and I was like please
don't take the Perpetual don't do it he
went and took the Perpetual uh when
you're surprised out of the opening yeah
the the Instinct and I think that's a
really proper way of putting it is to oh
oh you know neutralize what's going on
jump in uh preparation where you get
caught if you will yeah there's
definitely a little bit of panic that
you feel immediately right but if you
are playing with the white pieces
you think that you'll figure it out
because white should always be okay now
if you're playing with the black pieces
and you walk into preparation then
you're panicking and trying to find a
way to equalize and neutralize that a
new idea yeah right Amira jump in you
have a lot of experience maybe where you
prep out prepared somebody or vice versa
well this is true but they also want
wanted to add that well at the modern
era the value of the novelty is really
relative especially when I was doing
commentary for the top events I realized
that those elite players they analyze
almost every possible move at every
possible position so it's not that easy
to surprise now like a top player so I
think that they're extremely well
prepared and especially that at home now
with the use of the computers you can
push your preparation a very very deep
and one of the players who impresses me
the most by doing so is Fabiano caruano
he knows I think almost every opening
and if you remember the game when he
played against Maxim Michelle grave at
the second leg of the candidates in
yikaturing book and he unleashed the
novelty in the neither
that was one of the most interesting
situations that I've witnessed in the
modern chess where Maxima shellegrav had
to face a computer preparation till the
move I think almost 40. if I remember it
correctly and uh well he had to find
every single move to stay alive in this
game and then when he sold his opening
problems finally well his mind was so
tired that he couldn't defend well he's
the end game so actually this I think is
a perfect example to illustrate how
things go in the modern era right I have
either of you had the experience where
you're playing and your opponent makes
um a sacrifice makes a move that
sacrifices and you think to yourself
oh dear I shouldn't take the sacrifice
because my opponents prepared it with a
computer but you want to
and you declined the sacrifice fearing
preparation fearing the chess engine
and then after the game you ask your
opponent well what if I had taken and
they say I'm sorry I mixed up my
preparation so your opponent mixes up
their preparation and you don't take
advantage of it because you're afraid
that it was good preparation could that
ever happen I've done it myself you
mixed up your preparation and my
opponent thinks I'm playing this Gambit
right and doesn't walk into it because
they're afraid I have something prepared
meanwhile I'm thinking please don't take
how about you Almira have you ever been
uh wrong footed uh well I think it's
important to trust yourself so you have
to calculate even the situation is very
difficult and
um well I had another idea in mind but I
don't remember anymore
so yes I think that
um it's out yes that was the thing I
think it's the human nature is to go for
the concrete line so very often you will
be driven to um to the variation which
will encourages you to take the piece so
I think to decline it's simply out of
fear is completely irrational especially
for chess players who like to be very
precise right
exactly and by the way thank you for
reminding us of that story of the
candidates really it's still one of the
most extraordinary stories in the
history of Chess you have one of the
most important tournaments of the year
the candidates that tournament will uh
create the Challenger to the world
champion half the event was played in
Russia and then a year pause
and it was a double round robin and then
Fabi came back against mvl who was doing
incredibly well in that and uh well I
had a preparation like you said Almera
that went for almost 40 moves deep and
it was uh really quite an extraordinary
tournament a one-year pause in the
middle of the tournament yeah like hello
what I think that's the only time it has
happened really yeah I mean really
historical experience I wanted to go to
the game of Nana and Bella for a moment
because this was really a very popular
position I want to say in the 80s this
whole idea of the Hedgehog in particular
was
um
very very popular indeed D7 D6 and you
were saying Queen to H4 Knight B8 to D7
Knight C3 and some of the games that I
recall really went an incredibly long
winded variation let's say Rook here
Rook here and I think it was a game of
Gary Kasparov I'm not mistaken one of
the ideas that white wants to do is he
wants to post his Knight on G5 so that
he can play Knight to D5 and really put
some pressure on the pawn on H7 and it
was an extraordinary idea to play Rook
to C5
Rook to H5 and a queen over to A8 and
some of these variations seriously they
went very very very deep we have a
surprise move by Bella she played Knight
A6 Knight A6 okay that's that's a
different way list with the pawn still
on D7 right so I'm guessing Knight's
going to C5 that's a good guess yeah and
as I see it this move has actually been
played before maybe it's not the most
conventional
um but it does beg the question
after Queen H4
um I I thinking I let me play a bad move
for you if you don't mind for just a
second if you play D6 and I go Knight G5
and you go Bishop takes okay
yeah exactly uh can I uh oopsie days you
oopsie Daisy yeah I think I'm going to
be winning at least a pawn in this life
I think idea of Knight A6 one of the
ideas is that since Black's not spending
in Tempo on D6 yes what just wants to
play D5 so on Quinn H4 let's say D5
right away D5 okay so Rook to D1 yeah
I want to take and again I'm I'm really
I'm aspiring to play the move Knight G5
and I'm hoping
I'll force some weaknesses
E7 E6 just like that wow so the Knight
on A6 isn't uh an issue hmm
wants to go to E4
it's on on Route huh and uh
wow okay I'm uh I'm kind of looking at
it with new eyes for a moment I I mean
the conventional side of me is saying
you shouldn't really be able to do this
because I'm thinking I'm playing a
Catalan you know and I'm not 100 sure
what you're doing but we have a queen on
age four I think I've seen that in
cattle yeah yeah yeah yeah the queen
might well okay I mean I I don't know I
might end up on H3 one day uh we'll keep
an eye on this uh very important to
three I might go Knight E4 right away
Knight c394. well there you know the
whole idea of Knight C3 was to stop you
from doing this but uh yeah Knight takes
E4
Bishop takes B2 should I take the Queens
first yeah I was thinking that maybe you
want to yeah because
because Knight G5 might might cause an
upset uh take the queen first take the
queen now take the bishop I don't think
I'm refuting uh anything here to move
the bishop back well be careful because
I do have a trip yeah that's on my
agenda
um so you might go to E5 then
well hold on it's not that easy for you
right if you go to E5 you're giving me a
Tempo maybe to bring my knight back into
civilization I'm starting to look at
Knight D6
I might get
interested in the outcome suddenly here
hey bishop A3 was better yeah exactly
did you want to leave the diagonal right
right oh you're right because then I
take apart I know I'm good good morning
St Louis uh I'll take the pesky that
that's a good uh that's a good Pawn well
okay something to think about again
Knight A6
um yeah uh the changes of the position
it's not true
um what's the word I'm looking for
symmetrical
yeah
symmetry is definitely broken jump in
Almira this move Knight A6
um not
the not at all what I'm more familiar
with the modern practice statistically
speaking how does this move fair not at
all this move is quite rare so there
have been a few games but for example
the top game that they have in this line
was played by Vaseline vachuk in 1990 so
probably he originated this idea right
during the opening so he didn't want to
play Knight C6 I think and to keep this
possibility to exchange the light Square
Bishops I was thinking I just wanted to
show so let's say if
white Place Knight C3 black has this
wonderful idea of playing Knight E4 and
exchange a few pieces so let's say queen
E3 so then you simply take on C3 takes
on C3 uh Queen takes C3 and here you
have it Knight A6 goes to C5 of course
the computer relates this position is
slightly better or even much better now
for white because it is dated for a
while so because you have a lot of space
but I'm not sure if you will be able to
exploit it immediately so it's it's a
type of position where there is a lot of
maneuvering you have to keep an eye like
on the queen side on the king side and
always be alert so this is very
unpleasant with black and and that's
variation you just showed us with the
move Knight C3 beside the move Knight C3
is why trying to exploit this position
with alternatives to Knight C3 yes you
can play Queen H4 but for example uh
this move this well it's not featured in
the database okay so it could be a
novelty once again I don't have the
correspondence database there and you
have uh surprisingly have a lot of games
here so after Queen H4 the computer
suggests D5 right Rook D1 yeah of course
you're you're you shouldn't take on Z5
so E6 you protect the bone on D5 and
then well you can take this C takes D5
it takes D5 you can put your knight on
D4 which will be interesting but then I
think that this move comes in handy so
then you can play Knight C5 and Knight
to E4 so this is where we actually
understand a Black's concept
so um here's why it goes Knight C3 like
Yasser was suggesting can black play
Knight E4 after Knight C3 immediately
here yes Knight CS3 yes the computer
gives Knight E4 in the position well
it's probably equal after Queen takes
day took a takes d8 and then well it's
you you will have to make a choice here
because you cannot take only four of
course you can play Knight D4 but uh
well I wouldn't try this here I think
yeah no it doesn't look doesn't feel
right yeah it doesn't I was trying
Knight takes E4 actually against uh not
trading Queens Knight takes E4 Bishop
takes B2 Rook B1 I think is what Nasi
and I were just looking for yes but yeah
we missed something you missed something
in urine oh the night is getting trapped
on H4 what Bishop B2 then take on e4 and
G5
oh we were we were nicely going back
with the bishop we were thinking not to
allow oops there you go
that's why the computer is a good spell
checker tactical uh Checker by the way
just on that note because you're
mentioning correspondence games
so for me when I was I I started very
late in chess I started as a 12 year old
today five six seven uh but as a 12 year
old later as I was playing in
tournaments and coming up through the
ranks I was really stunned
to discover that people played
correspondence chess and the idea was so
remarkable for me that you would have
two weeks to make one move two weeks two
weeks because they would literally play
by mail right so like you'd get these uh
index these cards that would come and
say I take your bishop and did it down
in these games would last for years
years to begin with but the tournaments
would last decades
and I was like I was amazed when you
discovered that there was such a thing
as correspondence chess was it impactful
for you when you or were you even aware
well I think one player's play
correspondences now it's they do it they
do it by online so I think they have
just few hours maybe a day or two right
so I didn't even know they played for
years years
did you discover the world the amazing
world of Correspondence chess because
those guys analyzed
deeply their Novelties and you're saying
your correspondence uh yeah of course I
was referring to the correspondence
modern correspondence database because
uh well those games are the source of
major Novelties nowadays exactly but of
course like as you would say in the time
of your yes I was still playing the
tournaments where you would enjoying
games so yes it was fascinating that's
how people would analyze for hours and
when in correspondence chess but when
you would enjoying games you would have
an evening to analyze your games but I
loved the ritual as well the ceiling the
move in in the envelope I think there is
something incredibly romantic about it
exactly I will get to that as well but
again for those of you who are joining
us a little bit late we did have our
defending Champion
withdrawn from the tournament totally
reshuffles their standings because all
of her games are annulled
literally if you wanted Drew her earlier
in the tournament
it doesn't matter you're not getting a
buy but future opponents will get a free
day her games will be rated
okay so uh whatever the first four games
that she played will get a rating but
again her results will no longer count
towards the tournament which meant that
our whole standings got readjusted and
let's just take a quick look now with
humpy's withdrawal how that impacted our
standings Anna zetanski didn't affect
our soul later on as a townscape because
she hadn't played canero yet exactly so
she's in the solid in the first place
with three points and in second place
sharing four players yesterday it was
questioning against it needs it but
today new players Elizabeth
petsara and Irina Crush are sharing the
second place
now if you look at Alexandra Costa New
York Alexandra actually made light of
the situation and she said I didn't
think it was possible to lose two points
in one day but essentially that's what
happened one of her victories had been
against him that's taken away but then
she lost as well to Anna yesterday so
she got
but okay uh yeah she made light of the
situation but yeah it's a very very
awkward situation for everybody involved
and uh sorry uh for whom be although I'm
sure did not want to withdraw illness uh
forced her to do that Amira what has
caught your eye as we were bringing our
viewers up to date on the yes sir I
actually wanted to make a comment like
on a positive note yes this game which
Alexandra won against Juan picanero will
probably make it to my 60 memorable
games when Alexandra will write this
book so uh if you haven't seen it yet of
course please check this game on our
sign on our site and of course there
it's beautifully analyzed so uh let's
move to the game oh well between Arena
crash and
Elizabeth well I'm a bit puzzled here
that Elizabeth is still thinking you
know she spent well quite some time on
her next move so uh if not Knight E7
what could she be thinking about because
there is also a very natural move Knight
D7 but then she needs to consider this
move D5 of course exactly then it
justifies white play rookie one was
played so what happens after D5
it might change the structure here but
can black Castle long here because I'm
trying to get into Elizabeth's mind
right like into John Malkovich had you
know so is this variation possible
because yes she will have
um a slightly different type of
structure but maybe she will use the
fact that she's way ahead in the
development and the king is on C3 now so
maybe she can use this somehow
let's say for example if you will
develop your Bishop on D3 now we have
this move Knight E5 you will have to
play Bishop C2 Knight F6 and black has
quite a dynamic play here right Bishop
D3 is a rather uh provocative Knight F3
instead and again I like playing against
Pawn weaknesses Pawn weaknesses lead to
upon losses
and now perhaps Bishop D3
let's try this because I'm trying to
understand how this will affect I'm
surprised by the evaluation because the
evaluation exactly yeah
you think it sticks out like a sore
thumb but the computer says a dynamic
play yes Dynamic plane especially I
think that while the Rooks are still on
the board you know we had this
discussion with Irina you know she also
thinks about uh those Concepts so should
you keep the Rooks uh how it will affect
the middle game which end game I should
enter so
um but maybe this is still not that much
yes after rook f8 and how should you
continue here with white because okay
you developed your pieces but your king
is on C3
if I take on F6 uh in the position that
you have on your board as again
Elizabeth the time
in 30 minutes 30 minutes yeah and Bishop
to E4 right I look at the bishop on on
your board Almera and I'm saying Bishop
on B7 is better than my Bishop on D3 so
I'll neutralize it with the move Bishop
to E4
and I am hoping against hope that she
takes reptix that in the long run
I always like that as as a as a
commentator annotation in the long run
white stands better you bet in the short
term the short term the computer is
completely
well if I yes please if I do dare to
disagree yes I think that here even I
don't know what computer proposed but
from a human perspective you have this
possibility to play Knight C5 and next
day five let's say you will make sure A5
this night will always protect the pound
on a E6 and if you play A3 I will have
this move also with my disposal so I
think that this position is rather
balanced especially that you have this
possibility to play Knight C5 and A5 by
the way what you just pointed out is a
hugely important concept this idea of A5
if you will so the idea of A5 is to stop
B4 and to secure the square in the move
A3 can be considered as a positional
mistake because A4 cements the Knight
but what you have to do as white as play
very slowly B3 A3 B4 and boot the Knight
away very very slowly intriguing that
the pawn on E6 which I would say hey
it's just a weak pawn it stands out like
a sore thumb computer says no no no no
no no
and one other result of humpy's
withdrawal is uh very personal we have
to redo our picks
because well the defending Champion
was a big favorite and she's missing and
if we let's first of all recall what we
all said so it should be just VAR and I
we change our tapes right
which is our well let's see okay I of
course had was brilliantly insightful I
had chosen Alexandra and she was leading
throughout
until yesterday
and this is what we have well well first
of all it's going to be very unfair
because we've got one player Anna
zatonski who is you know cruising plus
one a full point ahead we can't all jump
on the bandwagon and and says uh Anna
Anna so we have to play for second
so everyone wants to pick for a second
no everyone wants to change their
answers I don't think Sabrina would
change her answer
no so we uh
you know what what we have we have of
Evolution which is
oh but you're not allowed to pick on but
yes we're not allowed to pick Anna this
is a very because you know I mean she's
a
this is a very unusual draft I I I I I I
I I'm waiting I'm waiting can we wait
and see how today no no no no no no you
you you you you've already got the four
rounds underneath your belt oh you have
The Insider's information as well I mean
first of all if you were to change your
pick and to choose Bella for example I
was just a good friend would be in your
favor remember she taught she started oh
and two yes and then she won two in a
row I was going to pick Bella no really
yes I thought it was uh Jedi Mind Tricks
that I was playing
what about yourself out there are you uh
who's your pick after four well I stay
true to myself Alexander Christine
Alexandra customer and yeah well I mean
ah it's almost like one the the shows
there used to be these shows where you
would there would be a curtain and you
could say okay I'm gonna pick curtain
number three and then they'd show you
the a fail right and now you could
change your pick right uh I'd almost
want to change my
perspective there I think Arena oh we're
looking at a handshake coming up in this
game of Alexandra
um and Alexander looks very disappointed
yeah well I will because she is such a
fighter she loves to fight with white or
black hoping for a fighting game should
I say I chose a line where it's if she
wants to make a draw she can so you know
I'm gonna cruelly I'm gonna change my
pick I'm going to go with Arena I'll
change my pick I'm going to join Sabina
I admit I admit Sabina was the first to
suggest Arena but I'm seeing a good form
I'm seeing an inform Arena and I think
the game against Bella yesterday she's
going to put that behind her and yeah
I'm changing my pick terrible I know and
we have to let Anna know that we're not
allowed to pick her right exactly she'll
be surprised she's in the first place no
one picks her and here we have our first
result of uh round five right we have a
draw between Abdul Malik and Costa nuke
that's
I'm just picking up on the game of Anna
for a moment again she's playing a
player tie for a second harika uh
Anna like I said she knows these Queens
Gambit uh in and out she's played C4
takes tarika is here in second
yes oh that's right we're so concerned
yes yes she's actually being she's minus
one exactly uh C4 takes D5 uh Anna uh
once after he takes D5 I'm sure we
transpose into thousands of games and
Anna wanted to do that Knight takes D5
is an indication like Alaska variation
right right Bishop seven and possibly he
takes E7 so usually they play Rook C1 uh
something like castles let me just throw
uh some moves on the on the board for a
moment uh let's say Bishop E2 Knight
takes Rook takes this is an old idea of
Emmanuel lask or black gets to play the
move E5 trade a few minor pieces and to
get this position now
um why
uh might be thinking hey I've got some
kind of a space Advantage I want to keep
pieces I might play the move Bishop to
G3 inviting a completely different
structure Knight takes c3b take C3 I'm
assuming you play for B6 and I did
exchange already on E7 she did already
27 and you mentioned Rook C1 which is
probably the theoretical line sure what
about E4 can I play E4 here Knight takes
C3 B takes C3 I assume I'm supposed to
play E5 if you look at this position and
the bishop is crying like hey coach get
me into the game yeah let me out so
that's why I'm playing the move E6 E5
I'm hoping for lots of Trades and then
the bishop is liberated
just a small piece of information please
Bishop G3 it was played by Anna's
husband so yeah she played Bishop G3 yes
she's deviating from maybe her home
preparation right like yesterday she
chose another line so that's like Daniel
is pulling his hair off right you know
did Daniel win that game well let me
have a look I wanted to show you this
game so Bishop 95
Bishop G3 and actually the the move
which was played in this game is Queen
A5 not Knight C3 and Daniel made a draw
okay so maybe Anna is right
and I want to improve thank you for that
uh Nancy you were saying Bishop takes E7
Queen takes E7 quick question for you
here
um when I have uh traded those uh to uh
traded the the Bishops you're going to
be playing for E5 right so I'm thinking
I want to cross you up I know you're
gonna play for E5 so I'm going to play
the move Queen B3
so in this particular case the idea yes
right if you take on C3 the idea was I
wanted to recapture with my queen stop
my E5 to stop your Liberation at the
same time if you try to go maybe
right I was about to say you can't play
it again so because G7 sang it right
here I might have to go Knight F6 and
put the Knight back to D5 right okay
interesting so trying to cross you up
but we have a very special guest in
studio Amira back over to you
um Alexander welcome to the studio today
you made a draw uh first a small
question about the game were you
disappointed that this was a no game
finally did you want to have a chance
with black today no sir lift oh you can
never be disappointed it was a fast draw
was black after your
um after you lose uh was white in the
previous day especially I didn't only
lose one game I lost two games yesterday
apparently as it turned out which is a
complete nonsense of course uh yes I
wanted to ask you Alexander about this
situation well which affected the whole
tournament and you're probably the
player who was affected the most by
hampi's withdrawal so how do you feel
about this now the whole night I mean
we're discussing it and Nana also texted
me because she she also was very
disappointed to say nana and I uh two
like players who suffered the most and
of course I knew about such a rule but
you know I've been playing chess for
like more than 30 years and never such a
situation actually happened in my
tournament and this rule is so
ridiculous because I don't know how it's
supposed to be but you for my like when
you you win a game it's like your
property you know you you suffer through
it you fought well I mean you prepared
it's like 10 hours of your life you
dedicate it to your game and okay I mean
the result can be different of course
but you want it and then somebody said
oh you know
it's not yours anymore I don't know what
is what is the way I know it's a tricky
situation and it's very hard to find
like the ideal solution but probably
some players should be getting more or
less but I think there should not be a
situation where you just like taken away
your point or half a point or whatever
and
um well I was very very disappointed it
just before you know the game I realized
that actually I was lucky imagine if
both Canary and hierarchos Drew
you know I would finish the game with
plus one being on plus one and I would
start the next round being on minus one
I mean this is a ridiculous situation I
don't know it's definitely a question of
course the rules are the rules you
cannot change them throughout the
tournament but it just shows how
ridiculous this rules are and probably
they should be reconsidered and actually
I also learned I mean I I didn't prepare
today and I was lucky that my opponent
picked this opening but
um I learned that the same situation
happened in Saint Louis last year when
Carson was due okay only after three
rounds he was Drew and uh but
nevertheless he already won against
Yandy ponichi and Yani publisher I mean
benefit was like the benefit I mean
benefited a lot from this situation
because he kind of almost got a point
okay I lost the point and Nana lost the
point and I mean that's uh it's not only
about points but about as I said the
facts that we like uh spent so much time
preparing and playing and the other
players they're just getting a free
extra day and for me right now like
playing the third tournament in a row
I'm like running on energy so much and
then like points just getting you know
it was stolen from me that's completely
I mean it's it's I mean it just feels uh
unfair okay I know there is a tense
price that is left probably it should be
distributed between the players who
actually play this game somehow you know
four players did play this game and they
did spend their time so yeah I don't
know again it's a very unfortunate
situation of course health comes like on
the first place we know that we don't
discuss it but what we what I try to to
make a point that it's it just feels
very unfair you've finished the game if
you finish I mean already very hard game
right I lost yesterday uh you finish uh
like your situation is plus one and
everything seems to be okay but then you
suddenly realize that you are on 50
percent
yeah thank you Alexandra and I really
hope that Fida will take this situation
into consideration and this will set up
a precedent and maybe a few things will
be changed in the future thank you
thank you Alexandra competitor indeed as
she's really feeling uh the uh
withdrawal and what it means as we come
up to our first break of this uh round
five it means that we should
check in with our friends at Q Boutique
and see what today's special is we have
for you a men's and women's polos
this is the official Polo of the 2023
Karen's cup chess tournament it is
crafted from 100 polyester and features
the Karen's Cup logo on the left rest
and the St Louis chess club logo on the
back of the collar stay comfortable and
stylish while you make your next move
available in men's and women's Style
only on Q Boutique St louis.com and
we're going to be back on the other side
of this break thank you
[Music]
hello everyone this is wgm and former US
Women's Champion Sabina foyer I'm very
excited to be here in San Luis at the
Third Edition of the Karen's cup I'll be
taking over San Luis chess club social
media accounts so please if you want to
interact with me and see more behind the
scenes actions and videos of the players
be sure to follow Sandler's chess club's
social media accounts
it's your move the muni premiere of
Chess plays the muni through July 11th
sponsored by St Louis chess club and the
World Chess Hall of Fame for
ticketsmuni.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States boasts the world-class St Louis
chess club and the World Chess Hall of
Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
welcome back everyone we have one result
so far in round five and it was a drop
between Abdul Malik and Costa nuke
exactly and we have a buy for gune today
in round five due to illness uh
our defending Champion
hero did withdraw let's jump right into
the play in the all Georgian matchup I
want to say that we have a theoretical
dispute going on Knight takes E3 Bishop
takes E3 Bishop takes three C3 Queen
takes C3 the players have reached a
position uh played uh several times in
the past and Knight C5 as well as D5
have been the two conventional moves
Queen C7 has played uh the the current
moment is a novelty
um I think D5 has been played before
n9c5 exactly and queen E3 quickly played
I was about to say that uh the Queen's
head into age six yeah uh we see that
black is preparing the move D5 in a
nicer way the move Queen E3
I like to call that a dual uh purpose
move
gift meet upon I do want to take but
also the second I have well a threat
might be strong but I have the idea of
playing Queen H6 if I can set up this
pattern we should all have this High
hardwired into our Consciousness Queen
H6 Knight G5 Checkmate on H7 so Queen E3
was the last uh move that's a thing for
white if Queen H6 doesn't work out
there's H4 H5 H6 ideas once you get your
queen on H6 right so for example if I
play I don't know a conventional move
like D6 what you're saying is if I
eliminate
you still have H4 H5 indeed uh let's uh
take a look uh I want to go to the game
of Arena and Elizabeth because the
players reached this position with 97
something that we had been following I
had played the move Knight F3 with the
idea well development development good
knight F3 Bishop to D3 and away we go
Arena said let me capture some space on
the queen side B5 if the Knight comes to
C6 sort of like I want to tag you and
push you away from
um
attacking the pawn on D4 Elizabeth said
okay I'll put my knight on D7 play the
move A5 provoke B5 I always love this
don't ask me why but whenever I had
these positions where I developed my
Rook for free without moving The Rook I
was like yes yes this was a small
victory because often in the English
opening yes exactly that a file is open
and The Rook is sitting on an open file
very very nicely Arena said no no not
for you I will continue with my space
grabbing ways B5 and we're up to date on
this board I pretty pretty cool yeah I
was going to say from the engines
perspective the engine says black is
just fine
from the human perspective I actually
like white I actually like the space I
like playing Bishop D3 and somehow the
king feels actually kind of comfy on
this unconventional yes but black has
done nothing wrong so that's why and
there's no weaknesses that you could
point to in Black's camp and say ah you
I'm going to punish you for having done
X or uh why our tournament leader uh
very surprising Anna zazanski she comes
into this tournament the lowest rated
player in the field she scored three out
of four to take a clear one point lead
heavily underrated player and there you
go she'll appreciate you very much for
having said that somehow she she has
been playing a variation that funnily
enough her Grandmaster husband Daniel
Friedman had this position as white
Daniel played the move Bishop it's to a
G3 and as Almera was telling us that
this was a game of Daniel I had this
picture in my mind husband and wife
doing the dishes together just washing
and drying the dishes and Daniel's
saying to
why didn't you play Bishop G3 why did
you follow my game and and uh Anna's
saying but a sweetheart I don't study
your games
who studies your games nobody's
interested
what do your husband and wife do uh no
that's not what happened in fact we do
have a setup uh again uh Queen's Gambit
declined I can imagine on a good day you
would like to get a minority attack
started with B4 if I was in harika shoes
I'd probably want to play A5 just to
slow down such an idea so maybe Knight
f694 is an idea for Black Knight F6 94
you bet I would expect in fact I would
very much expect that black will be
aspiring to do that
and there we have it uh getting caught
up one game already in the in the
history books uh a quick draw
between John Saya and Alexandra there
you go
there you go
and uh I just wanted to say that uh
thank you to our audience for coming and
sharing your day with us tell your
friends where you're hanging out but
also I'd like you to enjoy and join the
conversation and there's a way for you
to do that okay can send us your tweets
you're using hashtag Karen's cup or you
can tag us using set Lewis chess club
YouTube twitch channels and I think it's
the same handle for Instagram Twitter
Facebook all across all social media
outstanding and that's the way you do it
join the conversation we love to be
stumped by your question and we're
getting it set up for a very very
special guests here in the St Louis area
we're not quite there but okay we've
just seen castles and you like the move
Knight F6 for harika I was thinking
about that and I was wondering
after I jump with Knight E5 a key
question for you how do you how are you
going to handle Knight E5
I have a couple of different options yes
yeah what do you want me to say I was
thinking that you were going to play
Knight D7 I I'm planning you know just
to challenge my night because the crazy
part is
I didn't think a trade of knights was
particularly beneficial for me so would
you consider F4 or is that too much
against Knight D7 yeah might have
yeah okay we are ready with a very
special guest with Almira
over to you yes I'm joined in the studio
by Nick vergon welcome good to be here
yes thank you Nick you serve as
executive uh vice president yes if I'm
not mistaken and chief marketing and
Communications officer for Ascension
please tell us more about Ascension and
what is your role there we are the
nation's largest non-profit Catholic
Health Care System we're based here in
St Louis and uh I oversee our marketing
and about eight or nine years ago I
reached out to Rick singfield and said
how can we help heal North St Louis
County in the Ferguson area and we came
up with a non-profit called your move
chess which is really about creating
more access at the Scholastic level and
you know Rex has been committed to that
in the chess club and so it funds all
the after-school chess and Ferguson and
I fell in love with the game about 10
years ago my wife played and she taught
my son and I learned at the same time
and I believe that chess is an amazing
game to help create life skills for
children to reinforce the love of
learning particularly math and music
there's a lot of similarities and it's
something that you can play for life
it's just amazing families play together
my family plays together and so I'm so
proud in St Louis that we thanks to Rex
and his vision we've become the
epicenter of global chess here and
that's something that our community as a
community leader we take enormous pride
in
well and I have an exclusive piece of
information that you're an avid chess
player yourself you love chess and you
follow uh videos on YouTube I do so I'm
a big big Daniel narditsky fan his speed
run so I started watching that a couple
years ago and I've improved my chest.com
rating from about 1400 to 1800 and so my
wife jokes that I spend more time with
him than I do her watching him and I
love watching Eric Hanson who's a good
friend and John Bartholomew and I think
you know part of what St Louis has done
and and the chess club and wrecks and
his vision is created this ecosystem
where people could stream now you know
10 years ago five years ago that didn't
exist and now with car was one of the
biggest streamers uh Magnus is streaming
you have people like Daniel and John
Bartholomew and the chess bras and it's
helped create this ecosystem of Chess
that is not only transforming St Louis
but really I mean chess has boomed over
the last few years and I think St Louis
and the chess club and Rex and his
vision and what he's done has helped
spur that
indeed and um well I think that you also
have your own YouTube channel I do you
know a couple months ago I'm a historian
by Nature I've written five books and I
started a YouTube channel uh about
history and so my brother and I and
we've created over 100 films in the last
month and a half two months we have a
100 000 views a thousand Subs if you go
to Nick ragoon on YouTube and it's
really about telling stories and at some
point I'm going to do something on Bobby
Fischer maybe Fisher spots again I know
we had a great exhibit here on uh at the
Chess Hall of Fame on on 72 in the world
championship and I love telling stories
and I think uh the chess story
particularly during the Cold War era
when chess was a proxy for you know the
larger battle between East and West as
you know uh telling that story and so
I'm looking forward on my YouTube
channel at some point and I want to
interview Rex which I think would be
amazing but I wanted to and he's met
Bobby Fisher I want to tell that story
uh to introduce it to younger kids who
play chess who don't know who Bobby
Fischer was or they don't know uh in in
1972 how chess for a couple months
during the summer was the most watched
thing on the planet and I just think
that's an amazing moment in time well I
don't know if you know it's but that's
something you shared with Daniel
narajitski so I hope that he's watching
your YouTube channel and I couldn't help
but notice that you have this Ascension
Charity Classic I know that Ascension is
the big supporter of Saint Louis chess
program but tell me a little bit about
what is this sure it's our golf
tournament our PGA Tour event at Norwood
we created it three years ago again
similar to when we created your move
chest in North St Louis County was about
taking a sport professional golf that
isn't really known for being diverse and
inclusive putting it in the Ferguson
area in North St Louis County and taking
all the proceeds and putting it back
into charity so in this case the Boys
and Girls Club Urban League Mary Grove
and growing the game of golf in North St
Louis County and so we're going up on
our third year and I'm proud to say it's
the most attended event on PGA Tour
Champions it's most profitable and in
year two now it's already the most
charitable we gave away 1.3 million
dollars last year two million dollars
overall and I'm enormously proud that in
a couple short years golf professional
golf now is driving charitable donations
uh and making the game more diverse and
inclusive and and I took a lot of the
inspiration of creating that from what
Rex has done with chess here and
building an ecosystem that's about
giving back to the community
yes this is a wonderful initiative and I
assume you play golf I play golf I'm
probably better at chess now than I am a
golf if I was uh as good at golf as
chess I'd be happy but my enthusiasm
outpaces my skill that's a very
important quality to have uh could you
compare those two games yeah they're
both strategy based you know they're
both about thinking moves ahead I mean
chess is clearly about strategy right
and calculating golf is very similar
it's it's it's a marathon not a Sprint
you're thinking ahead and you're
thinking about where to place the ball
and and how to compete and I think
there's a lot of life lessons to be
involved with chess if you're younger
you learn how to plan and you make
decisions and strategize and decisions
have consequences golf is very similar
and in fact I sit on the board of first
tea which is an organization that
introduces golf to young kids
particularly in underserved areas and I
think chess and golf are two life skills
if you're a younger kid that you could
take with you forever you could play it
forever and it's also good you know if
you become a business person you need to
know how to play golf and if you're uh
if you learn how to play chess that's
something you can do for your whole life
uh thank you very much I have one last
question I know that you follow the
tournament every day uh who is your
favorite to win this tournament you know
I'm curious to see if Annika hold on I
think having an I am win would be a big
deal I'm sure she'd get a GM Norm uh and
so I think you know with with humping
withdrawing it changes it a little bit
but uh I'm rooting for her I'd love to I
think it'd be great for the game to have
an IM win a tournament that's
predominantly GM's and I've loved
watching the action I just think it's
fantastic and I think the Karen's cup
has become in a short amount of time the
premiere event it's
Landmark on the chestnut
a very insightful interview thank you
for having me thank you Nick very much
indeed I didn't know about Nick's
History Channel uh but uh I encourage
you Nick please do interview Rex because
Rex is one of those people that not only
loves history but loves in particular St
Louis history and whenever you get into
a conversation with Rex about Chess
he'll be the first to point out that St
Louis hosted the first world
championship ever along with New York
and New Orleans uh steinit zuker tour in
1886 and he'll point out to you there
was the home of T.S Eliot and there it
is and he loves the history of St Louis
by the way I wanted to jump into the
game because I was very surprised as an
answer to Queen E3 came Queen C5 Bella
essentially provoked Nana into doing
something that she wants to do which was
to play Queen H6 now after Queen H6 the
threat of Knight G5 is such a I want to
say terrifying Terror
you have to take the night kill it you
have to kill it you have to give up a
very very good Bishop Bishop takes F3
I'm assuming the Rook is going to go to
d8 yeah I would think that Rook C8 is
actually a more attractive move the half
open file there is unfortunately a
tactical issue with that so after Rook
V8 Rook D1 well I mean it's it feels
like a nice Advantage for white uh more
space can go to E5 and then if necessary
if the attack becomes too strong
exchange it on G7 or offer an exchange
and yeah white does have a pleasant
Advantage because we have a bishop
against Knight in an open position but
I think black can hold
this game if played accurately okay just
to continue a feature I think because
you know again I love these outposts
Rook on D5 makes it very pleasing
impression Queen G7 Queen H4 when I'm up
I'm ahead in space I want to keep pieces
and on the board I'm kind of
it's easier for me is what I want to say
I I I I feel I have more fluid fluidity
in the position and
F6 is not a move that you particularly
want to play your queen on G7 but okay
we'll keep an eye on this one and Almira
uh jumping over to you uh what has
caught your eye in this round five I
just wanted to come back to this
position which you had on your board and
uh the very usual move that we see
nowadays I think that you could try to
move H4 here you know I think it's a
very interesting continuation right yes
so uh this of course you threatened to
play H5 to maybe to open the H file to a
King G2 and then bring your Rook to to
H1 more than more than ever I'm thinking
Queen G7 has to come to kick that Queen
out of the way let's say queen A5 right
of course so maybe now your move Rook 81
right Queen G7 yeah and now that they
provoked it so I can play Queen E3 I
like the uh to keep the Queens on the
board of course and then if you what can
you try here let's say Knight C5 because
well I'm feeling the pesky on E7 needs a
little protection oh yes I can take this
I haven't even seen this so Queen A3
actually poses a lot of problems so good
issue are you going to play Queen F6
here yeah okay sure I would and now age
five right
and this is where King G2 Rook H1 it's
easier to play White and they'll
actually put the Rook on B8 instead of
d8 okay
I don't know if that's I think maybe she
was afraid of Bishop B7 at some point it
would be
and or she wants to give herself the
option of B5 but on the same hand
it is a question of tempos too right
Tempe Rook D1 the differences right D6
off my queen I kinda like maybe you'll
go Pond hunting Queen A3 H4 Queen takes
H5 King I don't know
upon hunting I would never go back
all right well uh we'll definitely keep
an eye on that let's continue our walk
around uh the playing area uh we do have
some moves in uh Castle bloom yeah
didn't see that coming I thought she was
going to play Maybe Roxy and Castle
short uh keeping well there is a decent
uh-huh
castles long let's just go with that for
a moment Bishop to D3 Rook E8 and this
move I find uh perplexing the move
Knight on e4 to to D2 so uh it's sort of
like you play Knight D D2 and then you
come and you ask your engine what should
I play and the engine will say we'll
play now before right so I always was of
the opinion whenever my opponent would
Retreat their pieces it would be like
I'd almost want to say Well done keep
going backwards keep going backwards but
I think maybe she wants to exchange the
Bishops maybe she wants to play that's
exactly what it's all about she's
probably thinking I need to get this
Bishops off the board personally I would
be saying the Knight on e4 is kind of
good there's no weaknesses for me to
attack
no trades I would say let me take a
little space let me just play a move
h2h4 give my opponent the move if you do
nothing if you I don't know playing your
move like King B8 well now that I'm here
let me take a little bit more space
it's not that I'm necessarily making a
rook lift but
it's sort of like one of those one of
those moves that makes my opponent think
well I should play H5 ah now that I've
now that I've done the old Jedi mind
trick on you now I've got the square G5
so H4 on H4 black can play E5 I think
that's another reason
it's very concrete if it works okay then
black would just get rid of all issues
so so your idea is that I You're Gonna
Go Knight G6 and got the pawn back and
improve my position greatly
that is a nice that that's a nice idea
I'm sorry E5 was not on the horizon so
92 two purposes uh first one is to as
you correctly pointed out let me get rid
of your best piece trade Bishops but
maybe I'm here to stop E5 okay
92 and how does the Oracle like the
position for Elizabeth and Irina
um is white
better is it balanced uh it's quite
balanced it's well as you can see the
variations it's like slight slightly
better for white but it nicely mentioned
a very important move here so for
example if you play Knight if wait a
second I tried to V8 here and if you try
Knight D4 E5 is a very important idea of
course in this position and as you can
see black is already a little bit better
and the most important things that um
you will no longer have this powerful
center right you will exchange the C6
spawns against the D4 pound and this is
a very good operation in this position
so the computer suggests here a very
mysterious move A3 which I try to
understand while you were analyzing but
this is way out of my reach so I
actually wanted to analyze the more
human move which I suggested myself and
I think that why I wanted to play Bishop
before and not Knight E4 because I was
hoping to play later on on the
kingside I think the way to play here is
to play G4 and H4 and this bishop on B7
is quite active so I wanted to exchange
the light Square Bishops and then to
proceed with my Pawn so let's see Bishop
C4 First bishop B4 let's say uh if
Bishop takes on the four you can take
with the Rook F4 and
um let's make a useful move but now an
IG Knight F5 actually maybe comes in
handy so I can attack it play G4 and
play H4 so it was rather Cooperative but
I think
um that black has another idea here just
in case
um if you play Bishop before computer
suggests C6 and why because he's trying
to make use of the king's position on C3
and to open this C file so
you will probably have to take let's say
Bishop C6 Knight C6 Bishop X6
and
how to evaluate this position I think
it's slightly better for black because
after maybe you can try and play A4 here
but then I will play Rook C8
and suddenly everything is looking very
harmonious for black and I think that
this position is more or less balanced
but what I wanted to ask you yesterday
do you understand this suggestion A3
let's say after uh here A3
absolutely a hundred percent the idea
behind A3 is it controls the B4 Square
what else would you like to know
um instead of by the way in the game we
don't have the moves King B8 uh played
we don't instead after Knight E2
instantly came to move C5 something what
you alluded to at the potential of
opening up the C file but for the moment
the king is still on C8 take a look at
that position because that now after
ampazon uh let's have on the board which
we have on the board at least Knight
takes C6 now the king is still on C8
Almera so you don't immediately exploit
uh the open C file now no seriously I
was joking a moment ago but if the pawn
was on A3 the move Knight B4 would not
be an issue right yeah yes you're
absolutely right but now it becomes
Crystal Clear why the computer suggests
the move A3
I mean you compliment the computer I'm
sitting there telling you A3 covers the
B4 squared uh but uh how does uh how how
is the evaluation in the current
position uh slightly better for white
now but uh I feel that uh this position
is really uh quite balanced because
maybe it's a bit more difficult for
black to come up with a plan here so you
you will need to wait and see so let's
say you probably you cannot play King B8
here because now I can play Rook B1
right so you know now white pieces uh
are more active for me because like the
night is on the seven and um
what can you do here yes sir from a
human perspective because I will try to
improve my night let's ah no now I
cannot do this yes rugby one will take
on B6 so it's not so easy maybe King is
seven here to protect the B6 pound but
now you can make your move Knight D4 and
here you have this wonderful Square on
the sixth yes so let's see I definitely
see some potential here uh which uh
brings me to the question that I wanted
to ask both of you from the human point
of view we have the position Knight E2
would you have played C5 C7 C5
yes because I don't like to see it
passively okay so as long as I'm not
really weakening my king side and the B6
spawn too much right I would want to
play C5 and activate at least my knight
only seven right so for me I see the
move C5 as actually helping white uh in
the sense that you're giving me a very
very clear plan there's this backward
Pawn on B6 that I could focus on but
here it comes after B takes C6 and
Knight C6 yeah you have hanging pawns
different D4 consider the hanging ponds
right that's right and your king is on
C3 so long term I'm using your favorite
long term black king and I don't b8a7 so
okay somewhere there and I can put Rooks
on C8 and d8 right and try to explore
okay King situation so here we go so
this is it this is the the great stuff
that's going on the Battle of Chess
ideas so you've explained closed
potentially uh your part on B6 and let's
just go ahead and jump rope B1 King B8
right maybe A3 first yeah and maybe a
three first rugby two
A3 to spend a Tempo on A3 otherwise
night before is unpleasant it was it
exactly what moment so here so 1961 I
can already go night before okay Rook be
one night before
oops rookie one night before hitting the
bishop hitting the pawn the pawn goes
with check that's yeah I was I was going
to say yeah the pond goes with check so
okay fair enough I have to go A3 we
surrender to Oracle exactly King ba Rook
B1 well here is what I wanted to do I
wanted to say
I hate pins I hate getting tied up if as
white I get to play the move Rook B1
let's say you go for argument's sake I
don't know if this is what you wanted to
do
yeah and you get your Rooks oh you
wanted
okay fair fair so Rook B2 Rook C8 Rook
B1
Rook d8 this Knight's not moving right
yeah I think bucks would play E5 at some
point at the right moment because
yeah at a certain moment that's coming
right so uh I'm just saying that for
arena
did she play E3 by the way yes okay A3
just taking away Knight B4 option for
arena you know I can imagine you know
her saying okay now I've got a plan I've
got the plan of attacking this the B6
Pawn so what I was going to say is that
as black in uh Elizabeth's shoes I might
have been more attracted to the move
King B8
and letting white make a commitment I
don't know it's it's kind of funny right
like let whites hi A3 is such a good
move even in this position without C5
it's a prophylaxis move right and if I
could get you to play the move rookie
too then the move C5 it's a little bit
more attractive to me because you're not
going to double up on the B file so
quickly intriguing intriguing let's go
to Amazon before we go to our next game
you'll be happy to see that Bella's gone
Pawn hunting
her Queen is on A3
what can I say I mean we're we're
handing out all kinds of gold
memberships in uh the pond grubbers uh
getting crowded yeah it's getting
crowded at the Top Gold members okay uh
just very quickly Anna uh leading the
tournament she's played the move Rook B1
she played in the movie of B1 looking to
play the move uh before minority attack
harika in my view very properly stopped
her A5 rookie one a flexible move uh
keeping ideas not just of e3 E4 but
ideas of 95 alive then harika made a
decision I'm not
I'm not really sure about this one did
you like the move A4 like kind of
thinking it might be just time 94. yeah
to drop in the reason why A4 you're
you're making B for that much more
attractive yes I've developed your Rook
Maybe
I don't know would you
is this a a line of play you would
consider
in this case I've got an outpost and it
could be 45 yes potential for B4 B5
maybe maybe B4 will give Anna something
to play for on the queen size maybe
small something Advantage something
something
and let's remind our viewers of Anna's
tournament thus far our line score
undefeated right she has three points
out of four and both the games she won
she went with the black pieces well
that's doing it the hard way isn't it
uh draw Win draw win as she is the only
undefeated player in the tournament uh
thus far so uh we somebody said Pond
hunting let's go how did we how did we
manage to go Pond hunting this is and
the all Georgian matchup right yes
uh oh guess what
uh Pond hunting uh was a good thing
because after the move Queen A3
white said yeah white said I didn't want
to lose my pawn queen D2 uh
wait that's good news for black just a
second hold on what's going on so no I'm
worried about the Rook suddenly night
before
we worry about the Rook or the pawn on
it both well the moment I'm more mostly
worried about that so I have Rook D4 or
Rook G5 Rook B5 is awesome let's say
Rook D4 okay I can't I I would love to
take I don't want to so A5
um and now we can go Rook H4 and queen
H6 back ah Rook H4
and black would have to play F6 or F5
here in order F7
exactly
um
okay uh I want to say Amira that things
are definitely uh heating up uh these
last few moves uh from from both players
including the move Queen D2 was Queen D2
necessary uh well you had a few options
here with white and first of all of
course I I was mesmerized by this idea
of playing Rook H5 exactly yes but it
doesn't work unfortunately because after
G takes C5 Bishop B4 you always have
this uh very powerful move and which is
sufficient F5 so and after Bishop D5 of
course you well you can play King h8 and
this is it but then I thought what if I
double my Rooks on the D file can I take
on it too so that's how chess players
think exactly so I will play Rook fd1
then can you take only two so my idea
was to play a rook one to D4 now those
Rooks control every thing with the idea
of playing of course Rook H4 or Rook H5
next or something you know but here the
computer has this move he indicates that
the position holds for black because
whenever you play Rook H4 now you have
this Check Yes King Jitsu and you
successfully bring your queen to the
fort and it defends everything so this
doesn't work either so here
um
well played Queen G2 of course but you
could try and start with Rook D4 here
because here you cannot take on A2
so if you take
on a two then you simply play Rook H4
and of course black as gets animated so
you have no time to take the pawn on E2
so let's say computer suggests Queen B2
but this is a loss of tempo already so
now you can play Rook fd1
maybe Knight C5
and here you improve your other piece
and I wanted to play Bishop D5 so you no
longer can play F6 or F5 and then play
Rook H4 so computer thinks that this
position is much much better for white
but there is nothing decisive yet what I
like about Nana's move even though it
was not forced so Queen did too is that
she probably is getting she's getting
back to my idea maybe next move that
she's going to make is H4
so I think that you need to exchange at
least one Rook here or something I don't
know maybe Rook fc8 H4 and Rook C5
in order to diminish white species
potential
wow intriguing and the computer is not
interested in night before and trying to
exploit that maybe the Rook on D5 and
the pawn on A2 are vulnerable it might
be too slow I think yes Rook D4 I think
NASA suggested this okay of course you
cannot take Queen A2 because I don't
know maybe for obvious reasons yes this
one I happily saw myself so here the
computer Retreats Queen A5 you have
nothing better to do I think that if you
continue if you persist with your
strategy you are getting mated mated
well let's see Rook h4s
yeah F5 or F6 go ahead can you sacrifice
maybe something you should be for with
the idea of playing Bishop G6 with a
computer we're showing C5 what is C5
here instead of Bishop before you were
saying plus 4 after C5 oh yeah I was
making a more human move so C5 let's see
yes what does it change
yeah indeed so C5 if we take B takes C5
then it gives this check okay you'll see
the queen is trapped and rookie
wow wow so C5 is a Hidden Gem you know
you you wouldn't think of it naturally I
was
trying yes to think of a more human move
that I wanted to play Bishop before and
take on and sacrifice the bishop on G6
and then Queen H6 but C5 is a beautiful
idea so how can you react to C5
wow and if I take the other way D take
same business Drive yes I will give you
a check but there is nothing you can do
because then you had no longer have the
F7 Square in the run and queen H6 white
is completely winning
thank you for that and uh just to take a
quick look how the standings in the live
ratings have been impacted uh by this
outstanding result of Anna satonski
against the whole field it would seem uh
the two Americans Arena and Anna taking
all the Lion's Share of the scores
and the withdrawal of conero did not
affect the ratings the players who won
against her will still get those rating
points exactly and players who lost will
still lose the rating points so even
though Alexandra doesn't have a lot of
points in the tournament standings at
the moment she's gained rating points
because she did beat right
and John 16 points but like she said
during the interview she'll get those
back I'm just kind of mystified by this
whole situation going on between Bella
and Nana because it's sort of like
there's been kind of some chewing and
throwing and the queen was on H6 which I
thought was a terrific Square you
voluntarily well voluntarily is a strong
word you you retreated in order to
maintain the pawn on D2 I really liked
almira's suggestion Rook D4 that was a
very strong move yeah instead of Queen
D2 I'm thinking that in this fight for
the dark squares over there on the king
side maybe I should just be playing King
G7 kind of covering up listening to H4
well yeah that was my question are you
going to sacrifice The Rook if I go like
age six and are you gonna
are you gonna sacrifice them maybe after
Bishop E4 I will
uh you so you start with Okay so let's
say I go uh
H4 H6 okay H5 oh you do one okay so on
G5 I play Bishop B4 okay on G5 so
I have six well I wanted my yeah I
wanted my knight to actually be in the
game but Rook takes G5 is really
beginning to be well I hate playing F6
nope nope nope nope I have to take it
back so King G7 H4 if I have to do it
the other way
that's a little
ugly doesn't it specifically I'd say
yeah
um I was trying to cover the the squares
around my king H5 Knight
C5
I mean in this case if you go hghg I
might be the one who's the first to uh
you know plant my flag and claim the
open H file maybe you should be playing
King G2 Rook H1
yeah that looks good and what's going
doing on A3 I don't know I'm just
hanging out
I'm trying to be my annoying self and
just hang out over there okay well let's
keep an eye on this one go to the game
of arena for a moment and let's get
caught up because things have happened
takes a2a3 King C7 Elizabeth said why do
I need my king on A7 maybe my king is
actually better placed on C7 kind of
covers the D6 Square as well as the B6
spawn King C7 Bishop
C2 intimating that The Bishop's going to
come out that's the maneuver pieces but
because Knight on D7 is quite passive
but yes what's what's a good Square for
it we can go to F6 but then what from F6
right yeah unless you're ready to I
don't know Double Trouble uh Rook D6 or
Rook D7 and followed by Rook E8 yeah the
question is a follow-up with Knight F6 I
think we're from Arena's point of view
if she can get her Bishop to A4 she's
got more space a little bit more
flexibility she can play in the center I
think black actually made a move and it
was Knight E7
okay a little too a little bit too much
chewing and throwing from black there
maybe she was very
um unhappy with Bishop coming to A4 yes
she wants to meet it with uh Bishop C6
okay so 90 oh excuse me now I that
that's old analysis Knight E7 Bishop A4
Bishop to C6 yes
something like this
so if we
capture on C6
do you want
I don't know if I should take yeah no
it's not it's interesting yeah it's not
immediately intuitively obvious which
one is better right
well somehow I would rather my knight
and king be trading squares like the
night somehow on C3 would be a better
place so night coming fortnite end game
and all nights could be better placed
exactly especially blacks Knights on D7
and E7 aren't that great whereas white
would love to be putting a knight on E5
I think it's easier to play Arena's
position but this certainly it's not
obvious what's going on no that's
surprising if we go to Anna's game yes
after harika played A4 and you were
suggesting why it should just go B4
exactly maybe have a small Advantage
right I don't actually get the opposite
she played A3 which means she's not
planning on pushing B4 well she's
thinking that after A4 A3 somehow she's
tele transporting herself to a bishop
ending where you know she she's uh
saying that the pawn on A4 will be in
any Bishop ending at a Target which
might induce uh the pawn to come to B5
so in one way she's saying I'm fixing a
weakness in another way it's sort of
like she's denying her own play on The
Queen side she's played Rook C1 acquired
for me Queen D6 Rook C1 we've caught up
with the players I notice and I find
this intriguing that harika is resisting
playing the move Knight E4 and I mean in
our predecessors or to quote Gary
Kasparov our great predecessors were
very eager to put a knight on e4 in in
this case harika isn't and I want to ask
Almera uh does the Oracle want to play
Knight E4 or is the Oracle saying herika
you're doing great
I'm sorry
I got a two for one on that one I was so
surprised at the coat of guard because I
was asking myself exactly the same
question uh well sometimes I was playing
the Queen's Gambit and in this type of
structure very often you would play the
move Knight E4 but the thing is that the
difference is that the dark Square
Bishops are traded so the move Knight E5
is possible here and after 95 actually
it becomes clear that this Knight is not
very stable on e4 because I could always
play F sorry like I will be
I will always play F3 let's say what is
the move that you can make here
you want to make the move F6 I don't
want to make it
I was being provoked well I can play in
my G6 of course this is never a good
idea so even if you play Bishop F5
well I don't know what computers
suggests maybe he suggested time go by
Knight H4 native three back and then he
well actually he provoked H6 and F6 so I
don't think that this is a good idea and
on the other hand if you leave the
Knight on F5 maybe in a long run then uh
White will be able to move the bishop to
F1 and then play 93 Knight C5 and
Targets in the pawn on e4 so this is a
very interesting idea so maybe you
shouldn't start with Knight E4
immediately uh what is the other useful
move in this position maybe you should
start with Bishop E6 here which actually
was played by the way but if I if I if I
could ask you Almira instead of the move
Queen D6
94 immediately so no Queen D6 94
immediately and let's just say for
argument's sake Rook C1 so 9444
Knight D4 of course was a much better
move here because Queen D6 is an actual
loss of tempo yes it takes the square
for the night I was going to transfer
the Knight to the D6 Square yes that's
that was my point and very often in
these structures you are absolutely
light right you if you're given a choice
you can play 94 94 let's say I will make
the the move just to a little space yes
the past then you can play 96 let's say
Rook C1 Bishop D7 will make another pass
like a very strange looking move so you
can even play B5 cement the structure
and play Knight C4 right yes
so this is a very important positional
idea here actually I don't uh I'm a bit
puzzled why harika played Queen D6 here
because she was probably thinking of
transferring the queen to the uh to G6
and with the ideas of playing Bishop H3
but it doesn't work simply doesn't work
so after Queen D6 you can play yes
um
we do have the position Queen
yeah and queen C5 exactly
you know uh yesterday I told you before
the rounds started that I I was
expecting Anna well to play very solidly
today uh to comfort her Leader's
position but this strategy might
backfire I I don't know if Queen C5 is
is a good move in this position because
if I'll exchange on C5 you will will you
take with the e-pawn I will I wanted to
take with the D4 pawn and the reason why
I wanted to take with the pawn and this
but I understand I'm artificially
isolating my C5 Pond
but I'm getting what I think is a very
handsome Square the night on D4 so for
example yes you can play Rook to A5 and
you can let's say tie up my Rooks but
you can't you can't attack my Pawn with
this Rook and if I do get to play Knight
D4 well I feel like I've gotten a lot of
space so I don't know if black is
actually that eager to trade Queens
maybe she would like to keep the Queens
on the board
so after Queen C5 would would be your
suggestion here I I'm not sure I mean
it's kind of funny uh
let's say queen E7 inviting a queen
trade but not necessarily uh allowing
the structure the pawn structure to be
changed with D4 take C5 I'm just saying
uh Queen trades are maybe okay but don't
give me the D4 Square
if that but how does the engine evaluate
the position after Queen takes C5 pardon
me D takes C5 does the engine say even
evenish evenish yes I don't know why but
the first move which appears it appears
to be Rook C5 first of all the the
engine makes recapturing yes he's
recapturing The Rook because I suspect
that uh well he's anticipating that at
some point in the B file might get open
so then the c6s of course a very easy
target the bone on C6 so but here after
Rook C5 well you can bring your king
okay
king of Fate maybe I don't know
Rook C1 that doesn't really
doesn't thread anything but right yes
it's it's also it's a very easy position
to play for black
so the hurricane can press for hours and
here let's say G takes C5 I like your
move very much he thinks that she black
is still a little bit better but
proposes this move Rook A5 then Rook C3
because you cannot play Knight D4
immediately of course because you lose
this pound right 97
so Rook C3
you have to be very careful here and
then Bishop C8 I think something like
this bishop C Knight D4 G6 they're not
allowed to trade a few pieces probably
equal
wow and I'm just looking at this
position and it would be something I
would be very comfortable playing as
white because I think that the Knight on
D4
is just such a powerful piece Rook takes
C5 in uh in intriguing uh
Clash of ideas
it's just equal yes yes uh for for me uh
I think uh a giant of American chess
Sammy Samuel rashevsky uh won so many
games with the minority attack that
somehow I got hardwired to be uh in
favor of the minority attack positions
and it it's not always play on one goal
as Almera is demonstrating black uh
could centralize her King and uh play a
very very long game but I think Nana's
doing really well after
right we do we left the position after
Queen D2 I think Almira was suggesting
the move Rook C8 and H4 and you know to
just trade off a little bit of the
Firepower if you will Rook C5 Bonds on
H5
okay do not give white the time she
needs to play King G2 Rook H1 the queen
will reappear on H6 you will be mated so
uh yes defend
now you're too fast
right right you you you skipped the line
okay so how do I defend okay well let's
first of all ask you how fearsome is
your attack so do your worst Rook take
with the bishop okay let me uh prepare
to uh
uh grab that Bishop if you will
are you playing King G2 that is a key
question I'm gonna take on G6 first okay
HGH
oh I wish I could sacrifice the bishop
but it's too early you mean King G2 this
is flashing through your mind yes Knight
takes Rook over Knight F6 and if it was
your move you would make me brilliantly
with the move Queen h8 but Knight G5 and
it's still well
is it still a fight
you can play G4
right maybe uh you'd like to continue
the ah I might have a purpet
it suddenly reappears okay so but we do
see that there is some uh that's what
it's all about and by the way ever since
Bella put her Rook on B8 it has not been
I don't have to rush with all deception
night before I could just move back
let's say Bishop F3
night before Bishop back to F3 I really
feel that I have to contest the the the
line oh
wait a minute I also had ideas with age
six Queen D4 for Cindy to play F6 which
isn't Pleasant either right no no no no
no no I think this might be no no no no
no no no no no no no I'm uh
I'm beginning to feel the heat really
really uh intensely here for a second
um
because white has more than one ways to
continue the attack and precisely for
black to defend against all of them not
so easy okay let me be
my provocative best Queen A5
attacking your queen forcing you to make
a decision
if you want to play Queen H6 or not
Queen B2 is also interesting here right
and then again I'm trying to be my
provocative best take my Rook I will
recapture and so on age six you're happy
playing F6 I wouldn't go so far as to
say I the happiness is not my my tears
of joy aren't exactly streaming down my
face but right F6 is stopping Queen G7
mate wow
um good stuff this game is uh heating up
let's put it like that we're just going
to take a quick commercial break but
first our results to let everybody know
we have a buy going on also in the round
all right so far we have one drop
between Abdul Malik and Carson yoke and
bye for good night as Hikaru of Hikaru
I don't know where Hikaru came from but
humpy uh withdrew from the tournament
due to illness
and we'll see you on the other side of
the day
[Music]
the
muni's premier season bursting with
comedy's romance and Magic Begins June
12th with the muni premiere of beautiful
the Carole King musical
the Epic summer continues with Disney's
Beauty and the Beast chess West Side
Story Little Shop of Horrors rent and
Sister Act
single tickets are now on sale at
muni.org
in Forest Park
[Music]
foreign
chess club is the Premier chess facility
in the United States and is among the
best in the world thanks to co-founders
Dr Jeannie Karen sinkfield and Rex
sinkfield the St Louis chess club is a
non-profit organization committed to
promoting the game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the U.S
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sync field cup
Cairns cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over 2
000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
[Music]
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why Jess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game the World Chess Hall
of Fame has something for everyone to
enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
um
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back everyone let's take a look
at our results so far in round five we
have one drone between Abdul Malik and
karstenyuk and by round for kunai
mamadara absolutely and uh jumping right
into the action in this uh round five uh
picking up with Anna zatonski who's
leading the field by a full point when
we left it we left it with a an offer of
a queen trade she offered to trade
Queens offered tonight and offer tonight
Queen went back to B8 and I like the
decision that Anna made here she played
95 which really did provoke a knight to
D7 then the trade so now we are in that
quote well Bishop endings of uh the the
light squares and Anna's one Anna wants
to try to prove that the pawn on A4
could be a liability she's playing the
move F3
prepping E4 the bishop might find a very
uh fine Duty on the C4 square and this
move for me is an indication that black
is actually suffering a space Maybe
Harry has regretting the offer that you
really denied yes
wants to establish it again Queen to d8
uh Queen to B4 okay this is like do you
want to play the move B5 if you play
yeah okay that's but that's a really
important question right if you play B5
you you leave behind
um a backward Bond on C6 it's defended
yes but after white pushes E4 right
is going to be very easy yeah it could
be very vulnerable we like Anna's
position let's continue our walk around
the stage and this game is the game we
really don't like for Bella we think
that Nana has really picked up a very
nice I want to say momentum attacking
momentum on the king side once you put
her Pawn on H5 Bishop takes you could
just look at Black's position
all three pieces are on a and b files
while our King is completely abandoned
on G8 and when there's no Palace guards
it's a very good idea to ransack the
ramparts with the King to G2 Rook to H1
and even as we were coming on break
we had a little uh
talk with ourselves H6 takes Queen D4
checkmate
and then you said to me well now I
understand why Bella put her her night
on A6 and Erica B8 uh 12 moves ago she
anticipated this position and she could
run away with her Grandmasters thinking
exactly exactly so I'm anticipating
Bishop coming back to F3 but it looks to
me like black is doing really really
poorly as king
whoa inviting a peace trade a peace
sacrifice I beg your pardon each takes
if I take but if he takes D5 I'm pretty
sure it's lost she takes H7
G takes H7 yes
because I will force you to take H7 and
then King G2 and my king is two queen
and Rook versus an alone King not much
of the battle actually I think it's so
in fact took back very quickly yes and
this exchange can only benefit Bella
right because earlier in our attack we
were playing King G2 and Rook H1 without
htx G6
but now that it's exchanged black can
very quickly set up King G7 Rook h8 I
understand that you want to contest but
then I will have a queen D4 so first of
all let's try to figure this position
out because in my mind I'm looking at
the position and I I'd love to play
Queen H6 I'd love to play Queen H6 King
G2 Rook H1 should I like imagine I'm go
crazy actually Bishop 36 is very
interesting you could also play maybe
before I forget this move immediately
King G2 is awesome which is also a part
of my whole uh plan but am I isn't this
the line we just looked at where you get
your or your no I don't think I can run
here I don't think it can cut me off but
maybe here I can play
um I'll adhere so I only need to protect
h8 so let's say queen C5 so when you
play Queen H6 I can come back Queen D4
well you've always got that so you could
maybe
use
not always because you can play Queen
before here
Queen ah Queen D4 that's why I was going
Queen C5 okay so you want to go Queen C5
Queen H6 Queen D4 defend and because the
Rook is protected I have no okay fair
pair
wow um Bishop take okay sorry so how are
we starting it's hght
um I mean we don't have to go
sacrificing Bishop F3 but Bishop takes
Pawn takes could I go Queen H six you're
probably gonna go Queen she's seven okay
km7 oh you want to go King F7
so let me just
boy how do I
all I need to do is is magically bring
my rib to F3 right
give away the F1 yeah exactly uh I need
a Rover a bit slow right okay then let
me give you a check let me uh provoke
you to go King up the board pause here
I'm a pond grubber you know that I like
the idea of freezing your pieces but I I
prefer the Checkmate if I can get
my Rook up and over uh a compelling
possibilities um Myra are spidey sense
is tingling that maybe there's a
tactical
combination in the position for white
because all of Black's pieces are on the
queen side out of play indeed yes sir
and I just saw that Nana played the best
move in this position she played King
jitu and the computer is yes that the
move King G2 is winning for white wow
yes Nana sacrifices the bishop on D5 and
after he takes D5 white has a very
powerful move Queen D4 so you have to
run for your life now because if you
play Queen C5 Queen F6 with Rook H1 and
made follows so King f8 I think is the
only move in this position
so queen of six once again
yeah yes Rook H1 it's so easy to
continue your attack sure yes so now I'm
not even sure what move can you make
here let's say queen king D7 Queen F7 is
completely winning because you can
always take on uh D5 so maybe G5 yes the
king let's say D7 then The Rook comes
into play
King it look H7 was seeking somewhere
and cringy eat mate
so it's a very leaner wine very simple
line to anticipate here what can I
suggest for
for black GTX C4 is the move that
suggests computer suggests here and I'm
really surprised because he simply takes
back here so wow he's not given any
checks he takes on on on C4 and I
suspect that in a little bit later in
the line you would need those two
squares to mate so that's why he takes
on C4 so let's see what do you do here
you bring your queen to C5 now if you
play Rook h8 I think that you are not
winning anymore because after Queen F7
King C6 you no longer have Queen D5 so
you have to play another to make another
precise move Rook H7 here and now if you
play Rook B7 Rook h8 King D7 Queen F7
King C6
I was thinking about Rook C8 but this
doesn't work so Queen eight
and this wins because I think that after
Rook D7 you have Rook H7 maybe one last
defensive moves a move I was thinking
now you can make Knight V8 and you can
play Queen C8 Rook C7 and well Rook C7
made this is a very nice position but it
has to be calculated
so even though Nana found the best move
King G2 it's still not that easy and
straightforward she needs to find all
the precise moves to win this well first
I was the follow-up Queen D4 is
incredibly important here
I was particularly impressed uh in your
piece of analysis there why the quiet
move B3 takes C4 you know like I'd be
anxious to win my material back and give
some checks well Bella has captured the
bishop and said okay show me Nana's
playing like uh like the computer
seriously immediately Queen D4 as she
has set up this uh Bishop sacrifice
combination and king cafe is the only
move right there's nothing else I can do
um there's Queen C5 but after Queen F6
then I'm in a war situation
yeah the only other move I was actually
yeah but F6 is just such a
quote Luber mayor lavoivitch miserable a
miserable move after king of Fate yeah
is Queen F6 the only winning more but it
seems such a natural move right because
which one is also natural well King E7
and then you sort of like uh
you know like how do you intensify the
attack the queen E7 kind of keeps
Black's King you know in this uh mating
net and King E8 to escape but you're
running but you're not hiding but again
I I'm particularly impressed that after
D5 takes C4 you don't go check and check
and start capturing pawns but rather you
play the tags
and I don't think that the clocks are a
factor so much as the fact that it's
just a winning position a winning attack
for
uh Nana
yeah they have Nana has 20 minutes and
Bella has 17 minutes so no time trouble
here and by the way somehow I didn't see
this result coming I saw the trend two
losses for Bella two wins for Bella
she's fighting her way back into the
tournament she's almost like feeling
like hey you know this is going really
really well for me and suddenly this uh
incredible uh really nicely played
attacking uh game arena Crush versus
Elizabeth uh
isn't this funny that we we were talking
about how the King was going to go on A7
and one variation in the game The King
was on C7 by Elizabeth a few moves later
guess what the King goes to A7 maybe
maybe uh you you were talking
um
Nasi about the hanging pawns and how the
Rooks wanted to be on C8 and d8
Elizabeth made that setup but she had
put her King in the way now she got her
King out of the way
um your take on the current situation I
think black is completely fine I would
be
a little bit careful with white
because C4 default you know delicate
situation right okay uh Arena's kind of
captured a little bit of space over here
on the king side so imagine I'm taking
or you're recapturing with the Rook with
the Rook so if I post up something like
I'm thinking that if I ever play King B3
I don't want my my king in front of the
Rook so if you give me a CH whoa I am I
trapping your Rook I was about to say
are you trapping my Rook because the
king be 397. right oh my gosh I end up
having to play King B2 so that I end up
bringing my Rook back after Knight C7
um take it away uh Rook takes uh Bishop
takes Rook takes Rook B5 uh how do you
how do you anticipate this one going
objectively why it should be completely
fine just I think black has more ideas
huh I can sense that you disagree I
don't know if I disagree or not I I like
the space but I understand what you're
saying my structure if I if I could you
know scooch this Pawn over and my Pawn
structure was would be a little bit more
harmonious you've got two islands I've
got three so I think that excuse me that
wasn't my intention I
I'm thinking it's balanced but I was I
wanted to make a an argument in favor of
my pick yeah Arena crash but uh it seems
that the position's balanced I want to
go uh again uh back to the game of Anna
just to see
yeah that was interesting what you were
saying like maybe she regrets not
trading Queens but wait a minute
hold on is my Spidey Sense tingling and
Quinn's just got exchanged there's no
you're going to grab on this well yes of
course yes
seven
yeah
before
but then you're going to lose that pawn
and possibly
take take rupee eight okay take group B8
gotcha take take Rook B8 then you have a
weakness on B2 oh wait a minute
B4
so you want to you want to sacrifice
upon right
um
maybe just A3
for good reasons
okay yeah I think that that's fair
enough and that was why in the game
she didn't take on B7 she actually
traded Queens Queen takes A5 Rook takes
A5 and we're in this ending where okay
all of these pawns are on light squares
black has a light squared Bishop
um bad Bishops protect good pawns said
uh Grandmaster Michael Shuba of Romania
and he has a good point
Black's pawns are good the bishop may
not be good but uh do you like white or
black here I think white should expand
on the king side maybe go like G4 H4
King F2 and so on
it's obviously equal but I'd rather be
white
and black
I develop her King what what about uh
the aggressive
very aggressive E4 I
without the coins on the board E4
doesn't scare black as much she uh King
F2 she probably King up to kind of a
maybe a Prelude to E4 but if you don't
capture by the way I'm kind of anxious
to play E5 followed by F4 followed by
King F2 and your idea of gaming King
side space I do it first by gating in
the center she did play King F2 by the
way King F2 King f8 on the board and
here's more or less
a key question right uh if I take take
if six maybe King to E3
somehow my king feels a little bit
cocooned cocoon Bishop B3
your Bishop looks very uh well placed on
B3
I might have some
five ideas okay not yet though not yet
Rook to C5
inviting a trade I don't know exactly
why I would do that but okay
take take
so you know we're not in the bishop
ending yeah we're not in a bishop ending
yet a pure Bishop ending we've still got
Rooks on the board I still feel that
okay there might be a chance away
to exploit the queen side pawns but it
feels more balanced than anything I want
to go back to the game of uh abellas and
Nana's for a second because after the
move Queen D4
is uh
uh thinking and we've been analyzing
king of eight queen of six King E8
Rook H1
takes all of these moves uh very very
straightforward this one was the
surprise and we played Queen C5 and that
loses
we suspect there is no
answer but computer things in this
position white as women just winning
um okay can I offer a different move
than the move Queen C5 maybe on a good
day I could use the C5 Square Queen
takes D6
oh you're not you're supposed to be
giving me a checks and giving me a a a a
a a queen takes D6 oops Yeah no Queen E5
for me the blood spaces are so bad in
the corner totally uh just
put me out of my misery uh shoot me
Queen to C3 I mean there is Rook H4 one
idea
oh nasty Rook H4 Rook up and over yeah
nine minutes for 15 moves for Bella but
unfortunately for her the clock isn't
the problem it's the position I like
your book H4 I liked your queen D6 that
but those moves are uh Killers actually
that just uh wins uh Almera jump into
the discussion
um it looks like Nana's putting together
fantastic game absolutely uh wonderful I
was wondering what would happen if Nana
chooses another move in this position
which is also very natural to make so
when um black takes on C4 we know that b
takes C4 is completely winning for white
but the line is very long so what if
white plays Rook H7 of course it looks
very true it doesn't miss any
anything yet so you have the only move
here Rook B7 because you need to protect
this pound and also you need to run with
your king after Rook h8 so analyze the
very crazy variation so King D7 right
Queen F7
uh King C6 now not Queen C4 because he
will have Knight C5 you know and then
you know you're not winning anymore but
Queen E8 check so King C5
and now once again the only move which
is proposed by computer Queen A4 double
attack just double attack of course your
attack on C4 you attack on B7 so uh
black can play D5 here attention so
during the game you might be tempted by
Queen E7 but rookie seven and black is
winning but then Rook C8
King B5 so take on C4 now your King has
to go somewhere let's say king before
then I don't know the yes Queen D5 the
computer says and plus two this position
is well is relatively easy to win but
then here instead of D5 I analyzed
um a different move what if C takes B3
and I was thinking okay does the
computer suggest 80gb3 here another move
and he does
a takes B3 another quiet move in this
position uh well black spaces are
hanging here so what can you do here if
Queen B3 you simply take the Rook then
the only move in this position after 8
B3 is to play D5 right I cannot see
anything anymore and then what did I
calculate Rook C8 here
then King B5 uh Queen D5
C5 something like this and queen B7 so
this is the resulting end game after
this Fearless attack you're right black
would be happy to get this engaged oh
yes I actually have another question for
you Almira in the current position and
just to see the head-to-head uh how
these two players in the past have fared
with one another they have 22 games
played and they know each other very
well uh nine wins for Nana and four wins
for Bella Nitros and nine draws and my
question was exactly the move that Bella
just made I just noticed while we're
looking at the analysis what has rookie
rookie five we didn't discuss this what
moment how does white win here we do
have Queen D4 rookie eight so idea is to
just play rookie five and Rook H5 to
cover the H5 yes indeed so Queen F6 is
the only move otherwise you are going to
play rookie 5. so rookie five anyway
because you have to play but here this
move
G4 yes an incredible move of course but
it's also very easy to find because Rook
H1 if you don't play G4 Rook H1 and then
Rook H5 is start it's a draw because you
still have a Perpetual yes you have
nowhere to hide here so black white is
not losing in any case but after G4 what
if I start running after G4 King f8 let
me try it G4 here
eight
yes okay shade king D7 and I covered the
check with rookie seven yes let's see
what does he suggest something what is
the quiet move but here it's easy yes
you will play Queen f8 and then Knight
to seven Queen C8 is the threat right it
still feels like Black's defendant let's
try but maybe now you can take the Rook
King E6 ah King is six okay I haven't
thought about this oh come on F4
okay no no this is a very interesting
variation yes now that I have a more
human perspective in it F4 is absolutely
impossible to find here because it
doesn't even look like it's threatening
anything well if I check yes you want to
thread I want to take the Rook but let's
see Queen B2 yes F5 G takes a five she
takes a five but now it's you see it's a
draw he says it's a draw
five you first you have to give check
Rook H6 yes yes and then seven
where can you go here you lose the queen
probably yes or you lose everything you
can take everything here but F4 what a
move really G4 and f4 on the what is one
two three four five on the seventh move
of the variation
yes it's not easy to find at all so
you're absolutely right now so we do
have uh pardon me okay first of all Nan
has played all of these only moves like
King G2 Queen D4 Queen F6 now if she
comes up with the G4 we understand that
Rook H1 is a draw so she's not really
you know I must say that a lot of my
combinations
I was when when I saw that I had a draw
it gave me the confidence to think that
the combination itself is very good
because I knew I had an emergency escape
right uh so I could easily come to this
position and say well I've got to draw
on hand so again my confidence is
enhanced now can I find a win and then I
would start looking at G4 to stop Rook
H5 but she's played uh quite a number of
the key moves so far
once again uh G4 how did we get into
that variation uh we get probably online
right we we run for the hills as best we
can
and then once we got here we took the
pawn the
but there's no checking and getting so
many attempt injections seriously like
okay tell me why this check doesn't work
I cover with a knight oh you're going
that way and then you you just you're
just one before C3
nice uh wow okay that's really getting
on the the the walking shoes right
uh and there's no way I can
capture this King look at that
yeah the king just just floats right up
the board so no so this is where we we
took upon
uh you drop the rook in the way now
there's no run there's no running that
that would be uh
a stop sign
and here you came up with queen of a
threatening mate on the spot we covered
927 right so that we could go here this
is where you check me on d8 because my
Rook was
um under threat I had to play King E6
and this is where you stand as all once
again I thought is incredible yeah the
Oracle uh F5 check and Rook H6 The Rook
is tethered
F5 check on the agenda
wow quite the variation uh yes sir I
wanted just to indicate objectively
speaking there is another move which is
much easier to find I mean in the whole
variation again when white plates are
four let's say this position if I do not
see this move F4 because I once again I
I looked at the board and what do you do
after Rook G8 it's much easier to find
than the four or simply definitely which
is six yes and uh probably you will have
to give back your night
no I might I mean Rook G8 is far more
human I mean you know you don't want to
play F4 and expose your own King to some
kind of counter attacks but Rook to G8
98 yeah I have to give up the night yes
and then I will happily guys of course
Nana just played G4 G4
Bravo wow wow
she is amazing at attacking apparently
in her element for sure but nice move G4
and also Furious I think
yeah because of course she was one of
the players uh regretfully with home
bees uh withdrawal point was her point
was taken away yeah
well once again uh I for those of you
who are arrived late uh shame on you but
there was a an interview with Alexandra
where she kind of expressed let's be
honest she was fierce I mean she's a
competitor so you kind of expect that
but that loss of a point was like she
said how do you lose two two points in
one day and well
and and here are the particulars of our
reorganized event Corner's results will
no longer count towards the tournament
because we they didn't pass the halfway
point she would and that's funerals
correct and Upon Us in future rounds
we'll receive a buy which means a free
day essentially uh for her opponents
and of course it was an illness that
forced uh humpy to withdraw from the
event so there you have it uh a Pity
that our defending Champion is not with
us definitely okay let's jump to Arena's
game shall we for just a moment uh let's
see what has gone on uh we're talking
about the four nights here we go yes
95 checking between exactly what we're
looking at and uh I think this is an
indication that arena is kind of coming
up
empty-handed like she's played the Mover
of E2 you know it's not one of those you
know active forward moves
I think it's taking whatever sting there
might be out of Knight G4 just it's a
pass move session block Knight was going
to D6 Knight E8 Knight D6 that makes a
lot of sense
The Rook on B5 that's kind of awkwardly
placed true that uh 98 though are you do
you give me this opportunity I don't
know D5 I thought that was never good
never good Okay the reason why I I found
myself a little drawn to it I always
like those variations where I get King
A6
all these those variations where I can
tie you up a little bit you could take
on C4 too of course
and I don't have a an immediate and
Seether is coming with a check yeah I
it was kind of weird actually I I no
here you just go C3 check and you move
your Rook that's nasty I was your night
on E8 because yeoman's work here maybe
you rush with
Ray Knight D4 in between
okay
I can't pronounce that word yeah hey
finally uh well I mean I'm terrible with
names I mean and uh boy but uh I was
always
not the other one I would Lord it over
you if I if only I don't but Rook takes
D5 I agree I messed up my structure but
okay I got some Dynamics I've got check
on my agenda I've got rookie seven now
if you look at the position in last four
or five moves uh position has changed so
much white has improved
is Knight and both of the Rooks and
meanwhile Black's Knights and Rooks have
become extremely passive so that's not
what Elizabeth wants to happen she just
played the move Rook C7 maybe an
indication that she was like yeah she
wants to kind of prevent uh any ideas of
D5 and rookie seven so Rook C7 is on the
board I still think it's very very
balanced I want to go to Anna satonski's
game because Anna did play that
variation with E4 and well she's
inviting the trade of Bishops here with
the move Bishop E6
again uh you know we we started the
tournament with something like 80
percent yeah 80 victories uh in the
first two rounds but things have really
slowed down in the meanwhile now a few
more draws and it looks to me like a
draw is a likely outcome here again I
wanted to go to well the the game of the
round does not look like a drop yeah no
seriously it is a it's a great attacking
game by uh Nana
and
E8
okay I'm Not Okay Jade
that makes a hand makes itself right yes
you you can't prevent it I mean she's
considering Rook H7 exactly but Rook H7
Rook E7 not as convincing yeah 37 will
defend Black's position exactly so yeah
no Rook h8 I'm sure she's actually uh
fixed this position in her mind and the
idea of of pursuing the attack with
either Queen takes F7 or queen d8 check
is certainly dominating her thoughts
there's also a rook d a check but
it's less
effective less effective yeah because so
I mean even here Rook Cafe it seems like
white should still be winning but it
gives black time to to find defensive
moves exactly yeah you you might be you
know that's one of the things that uh
actually when I started becoming a good
player in becoming and really I want to
say uh a b player was
I was thrilled when I could check my
opponent you know any any check was a
good check as far as I was concerned and
later I discovered much to my chagrin
that sometimes checks can be bad for you
like you help your opponent by chasing
their king or allowing them to block and
that sometimes you should not be
checking your opponent this is one of
those cases where Rook d8 is actually
helpful I think that's one of the things
you'll learn as a chess player that you
have to be patient because you want to
make give checks all the time
automatically yeah but you have to be
patient and not do it all the time right
it's not necessary so again I think I
became a good player a b player when I
learned not to give checks I think I
became an expert when I learned that
sometimes my king could hide behind my
opponent's Pawn I know what you mean
yeah like the pond would go all the way
to H7 and I put my king on h8 might be
very happy that each file was closed but
we are expecting that nana will pursue
her attack as follows in this position
check king queen takes F7 check Rook
comes back to block the check Queen to
f8 threatening mate in one on the spot
Knight C7 to give the king uh an escape
Square
check
now your king can't go to C6 actually
has to go to E6 and while the computer
might uh say that F4 is better than this
move I find myself drawn to the G6 uh
yes exactly very very natural instead of
Knight C7 can black please
try Quincy five let's say I defense C8
Square exactly Queen to C5
okay
let's just
probably same idea wins Queen DHS
once again your king
whether desirable or not you can't lose
the Rook you have to and Rook G8 with
the same idea
yeah it's just that the Rook is too
vulnerable
just cannot defend
anything on the white squares like the
G6 Pawn yes it could somehow defend G6
black would be fine oh wow we have a
very interesting move Nana took on D5 no
check on h8 wow this cannot be you you
mentioned uh patience but that is that
it's too patients what is that
wow
rookie seven and is black just happy
piece now
yes yes
black is yes Nana Miss rookie seven or
Ken white continue here
well
I can see more than anything just one
check exactly the check and Queen no but
that's like hold on hold on let can we
take a look check and she's thinking
that she's got they're giving Queen a
shirt Chuck
well I'm trying I'm trying to imagine
what she might
have wanted I have Knight C7 Queen C6
King d8 and I cover on E8 right that you
block me that's right finally my queen
on A3 has been useful you're defending
D6 the whole wow so you could defend
with you could block with the Rook or
you could block with the Knight well
here no wait a minute
yeah no I I I'll happily escape with a
prepaid
but will Bella find rookie seven she has
five minutes on the clock I think she
has no choice I mean everything else she
can easily uh
uh sometimes you help your opponent a
lot when you make moves where they only
have one forced response and this
position takes you know you're just
looking and you're seeing meat and two
check king queen mate so he plays rookie
seven you have no choice but to play
rookie seven and then the shocking thing
if you're in in Nana issues is you see
rookie seven you go well wait a minute
my intended Checkmate on d8 no longer
exists
what did I do
and you're finished
oh my gosh what has she done Almira what
does the Oracle tell us uh this could be
a huge turnaround for what we thought
was the spectacular game
well this game actually reminds me of
the game uh Nana played yesterday do you
remember yes yes uh that hampi Connor
had an absolutely winning position and
the tables have turned just towards the
end and another one so here the
situation is reversed Nana was playing
brilliantly she sacrificed the piece she
made a few
like very tough moves but queen of Queen
Z4 Queen F6 G4 and now when she was just
about to win the game The Impossible
happened once again and now she's losing
Rook E7 and no more attack well the
computer says minus 1.5 but the move
that he's like suggests in this position
is E4 like which makes absolutely no
sense to me so and but after Rook h8
King D7 and there is absolutely nothing
that you can do no follow-up and
Queen h8
grenade this idea that Nazi suggested
Knight C7 is a very strong defensive
resource and it holds everything right
the night suddenly Queen C6 is in the
game that's probably what Nana missed
the rookie eight wow and here is the
blunder in replay because she actually
spent some time in capturing on D5 she
had like 16 minutes she spent almost
half her time
and came up with C4 today and sometimes
you know you just have this blind spot
The Rook can came back to E7 there's no
mate on d8 you know I would call this
overthinking thinking because Okay Jade
is such a simple winning move exactly
but she's been playing this only move
such beautiful non-forcing moves like
kimchi before Queen F6 G for that maybe
she got used to those kind of moves
because it takes D5 is just in that
style
by the way uh something for uh our
players in the audience uh and we have
Queen A8 on the board and we'll see if
Bella plays Knight C7 I love the
reaction of Bella uh when you're when
you have absolutely no other move
don't think yeah your opponent plays
Queen h8 your only move your only legal
move is King D7 I've actually witnessed
people thinking 10 12 15 minutes about
an absolutely forced move of course
they're not looking at this position the
looking moves ahead but play your forced
move and get your 30 second bonus Queen
a A8 and then again I'm thinking this is
a kind of a situation like a moment ago
The Rook was on The Rook had to come
back to E7 in this case there's no other
choice Queen C6 sets up the mate maybe
Queen B2 to not let but it allows rukage
right away so I would not do that ah you
mean yes I understand what you're saying
yeah so uh Queen B2 Queen C6 check King
d8 rookie like oops uh but Knight C7 is
just one of those moves you absolutely
forced to make the night has been
offside dare I say it since night A6 was
played in the opening the Knight makes a
triumphant return back into play night
back to season seven and should win the
game
and this game is over Irina and
Elizabeth have drawn their game it
seemed like like neither side I was
going to make progress in that position
did they just find a way yes it was just
a repetition three move repetition with
Knight
D5 and in King C3 I want to turn around
in Bella's game truly my pick
commentator's curse commentators curse
uh Queen
C6 check
um King d8 and uh yeah I think Nana
maybe just realized that she's not
winning anymore yeah and black is ready
to intercept is there anything else I
don't see any Queen C5 is coming and
well that's where I think E4 no no
pardon me I think the computer one was
early for earlier I beggy Parton yes and
now as we saw in almira's board it was
like minus four for black so it's
completely winning okay so let's just
see Rook check
Queen apartment Rook F7 oh you're
playing okay H7 Rook H7
trying Quincy five okay uh
it takes D5 oh that's a check yeah oh I
have enough Pawns in the end game to win
you know I was about to demonstrate a
really wonderful array of checkmates in
one
uh yeah so when your king is in check
you can't leave your king a check uh and
our results so far
we have we have drugs because
Russian pets and buy for gunaima Masada
exactly and we're two games still going
on and in one of them we might have a
result soon because Bella is happy face
and it looks like she has defended the
attack defended her King from the attack
and now is winning wow but it was uh
this move C4 takes D5 that really uh
spoiled a brilliant attack I must say by
uh and we do have
but I think game will be over before yes
because again Queen C5 is definitely on
Black's agenda any Queen trade it's uh
lights out
um
okay
I'm trying to get a here I'll show you
what I'm trying to do I'm trying to see
E3 Queen Neo right Rook check
okay I'm trying to gain some pawns for
my piece
check
I want to King is heaven yeah I wanted
to take this Pawn with a check yeah
eight
and how many I don't have that many
points does not have enough points one
two three four five six but I don't
believe it I'm losing one of them if
they were maybe connected passcodes that
would be one thing but here and one
doesn't have any passers and not only
that but it's actually blacks pieces
that are beautifully coordinated Queen
and Knight make a very good impression
safe King no this is just completely
losing I mean I can't I can't even make
any claims any pretensions of any kind
of compensation for the piece as King d8
this is like one of those horrible odr
moments you know maybe we're winning and
now losing it's definitely bad for Nana
but maybe Bella's getting her luck back
because in the first game everything
went wrong peace the second game also
against Anna
right a lot of things go our way so
missing the stair Matrix
wow but it's not just luck of course I
don't even really believe in luck she's
been fighting so hard and the two games
that she won
wonderful yeah she earned them so and
today I mean
the attack that Nana on court but it
wasn't yeah it was it was really really
nicely orchestrated starting with H5
takes G6 not an intuitively obvious move
King G2 she did all of these really
quiet moves Queen D4 Queen F6 G4 very
well she got into this position after
rookie eight and the simplest and
cleanest win started with Rook h a check
what could be easier than playing check
and
for Bella
wow she's about to have a third win in a
row after starting with two losses yeah
when they talk about decisive games she
does not make cross
the lady does not like draws so we have
a few moves uh Nana played Rook C1
clearly to avoid the Quincy five move
okay stopping yeah by the same time
white has no threats maybe Queen B7 so
Bella immediately responded with Rook D7
which I like now her King can escape via
E7 if you did and um yeah I'm pretty
sure next move she'll play Queen B2 and
finally bring that Queen into the game
or maybe Queen A5 one of this ways bring
the queen back to the game and exactly
another nice thing about The Rook on D7
is it just it just allows the king
to to go to E7
um and freeze the Queen the queen on A3
had a crucial role to play in terms of
defending the D6 Pawn now you've
released your Queen and as as you've
just so properly said Queen A5 Queen B2
once the queen gets back into the game
Black's defense is not only hold but she
takes over
shall have material and compensation as
a light's clock is ticking down two and
a half minutes for Nana and six minutes
for Bella
Rook
c33 gotta make a move some kind of some
kind of Rook C3 he's thinking Queen B2
or queen B4
still Queen A5 Queen A6 any of the queen
moves I like Queen B2 there's something
about Queen B2 where I I'm
I'm stopping you from even considering
this your Rook is hanging
I'm making you alert right and if you
play a move like Rook E3 well then I I
love your idea of just
bringing my queen back into play Queen
takes D5 Queen D2 takes down D5 roxetris
idea is to still hope for Rook H3 Rook
h8 well the beautiful part about Queen
B2 yeah it's like I've kind of uh I put
the kibosh on Rook h8 even before uh you
thought about it Queen goes back to E5
yeah trying to trade Queens it's looking
hopeless for white yes truly Blackwood
need to make a huge blunder for white to
get chances again exactly
Queen trade will be lights out
wow uh quite quite a turnaround and
again you were mentioning an echo Nana
losing yesterday against zombie no
winning
she was losing right and on move like 39
conero blundered yes
so today almost exact opposite happened
where Nana was playing a brilliant
attack and winning and in one move it
all switched and now Bella's winning
absolutely uh
a favorite quote of mine
and it's not mine it's vishianans vishi
was asked by an Indian journalist what's
it like to be the world chess champion
and you know how this she responded how
it was brilliant it was brilliant but
she said every day I feel like a
sportsman
some days I feel like an artist
some days I feel oh
all right hold on some days I feel like
a genius artist
some days I feel like a genius sometimes
I feel like an artist and some days I
feel like an idiot
that's what happens when you're a
professional chess player some days
you're the you're the player giving the
lesson other times you're the player
receiving the lesson uh this turn around
uh wow I'm a bit stunned by by
everything that's just taken place Rook
C pardon me Rook C1 hold on let me just
refresh devastated when you're a
brilliant game disappears in one move
your winning transitions disappear in
one move yeah it feels and it wasn't
even like a big blunder she didn't
blunder a queen or a rogue just missed
the idea that black covers on E8 right
the Checkmate ideas and we have Almera
with a guest
I have Elizabeth here with me in the
studio Elizabeth welcome back hi uh you
made a draw today with black against
Irina crash please tell me how did you
come up with this idea of playing H6
against Irina well actually it was not
my idea I wanted to play something else
and then I was discussing like all the
evening along with with my coach and
then he wanted something totally
different and I wanted something totally
different and then he came up with this
idea and I said like fine because
actually our goal was to get Arena out
of the opening very quickly and just to
play on ourselves and actually with H6 I
think I managed
okay so what did you expect did you
expect the movie Bishop before is normal
but what is unusual is actually like
that she played E4 I mean after Bishop
takes c626 E4 that is unusual because I
mean like compared to this line with um
where you sacrifice a Pawn on D4 here a
lot of pieces are already exchanged so
um the thing is like that she must be
careful about the default Pawn on the
long run and I even thought I I was not
better here but I thought it might be
dangerous for her but then actually
um I'm not sure where I went wrong
because before was needed because if she
doesn't play before I will go A5 Knight
C6 long Castle Knight F5 and then this
Pawn
might be very tricky
um while the default Pawn might not be a
nice fellow
to say the least long Castle but after
before I thought like that okay I mean I
understood that maybe I'm not better
here even so I should see that the
engine likes this position but yes
Knight F3 was played a five B5 maybe A5
was wrong but I didn't really know what
to do actually in this position I didn't
even know whether I wanted to play F5
and King F7 or short Castle or long
castle level so many choices and it's
always tough when women have a lot of
choices because they can never decide
um yeah so uh here I was very happy
because here I saw like that maybe even
like it's getting a bit tricky for me
because I don't have ideas but when she
played Knight eating too I was very
happy because I got this kind of
free move of C5 to get the space back
and here I think the position is around
equal I don't think that the game was
anything special or we missed some
chances any of us so here I was already
like happy that we can maneuver around
but nobody really can do much because if
she pushes she should get weak squares
and if I push I get weak squares and
here it's the same you know I was
thinking even like after Rook C7
in the end to play on but I understood
that even after for example like King C3
she played and here I mean if I want to
play on I have to play something like
Knight B8
a knight E8 I didn't even see oh not be
it so I know it is
this move actually was not coming to my
mind yesterday six ah yeah I mean I felt
like that might be something here but I
only saw like Knight p8 Knight E5 and
then it was nothing but 98 I just I
think I just missed in a way that this
was possible maybe you were already
happy that with the draw here it's not
like happy I was feeling that it might
be more than that but I mean in this
position if I had played on I would have
played Knight B8 so actually 98 for some
reason didn't cross my mind I don't not
sure why maybe after 98 I thought like
something like Knight E4
and then you don't get to 96 but then
probably you use the other night yes
maybe ah yes this doesn't work here yes
no an idea item is actually
I didn't think about that one
Elizabeth do you have your favorite
chest word because I know that Yasser
certainly has one so what would be your
favorite Chess World oh I don't even
know I mean
um something like this is yes sir's
favorite word but German that it's kind
of boring
so actually uh I'm not sure what is my
favorite chessboard I never thought
about that chest word I never thought
about it but it's definitely not side
note that's Vision soup it's just
happened to be German and English
language doesn't have that word I guess
so not sure actually Ella okay so it's
something to think about Elizabeth I
wanted to ask you about your upcoming
events because I know that there is a
new tournament which is going to take
place in July June July I think the
global chess League can you tell us
something about it yes this is a new
kind of format which was invented by
Tech Mahindra and Vita Tech Mahindra is
a
uh is a company from India and they got
this idea of a global chest leak which
is equal like to the Champions League in
football I mean kind of this sort of
style they composed to teams now and
actually I happen to be in the team with
um Irena but the funny part is like we
are on the team with the strongest guys
in the junior section and in the world
rankings so cool it's my first time to
play with Magnus on a team but it's like
on the one hand it's very good on the
other hand like I remember his faces
from the north from the Olympiad in
Chennai and sometimes he didn't look
abused when he was checking the other
boards so this kind of you know face you
you happen to remember from from the
past is is a little bit scary but
actually the funniest part was I did
some calculations yesterday and I
realized that like that the age of Irina
and me together could be actually almost
equal to everybody else
so that means actually we are not only
the uh crannies on the team we also
could be mothers in that team and that's
something which is is like yeah it's
unusual but
um yes we could be basically the mother
of kukash of arigasi of Prague so it's
it's sort of funny to have like such a
young team and the two old grannies
combined so that's sort of funny how
many players are playing from this
tournament are playing in the global
Chase League um I think it's Alexandra
then it's Nana it's Bella and
humpy
and now I'm puzzled I think
um that's it's those so far almost the
whole field you know the strongest
players in the world so well it will
certainly be a very exciting event to
watch thank you very much Elizabeth and
the next time well you have to prepare
an answer for the question yes I will I
will think about it
thank you Elizabeth as we are looking at
the game between Nana and Bella and well
as we would expect the extra piece is
what it's all about in this game it's
the clock but that's you're almost 39 so
they just have to make Bella has to make
two more moves exactly she has minute
and a half
Knight takes D5 what we all uh live for
uh I'm just thinking also well no I can
just I or she can simply play rookie a
yeah I want to trade Queen very
practical decision oh gosh is it ever uh
I mean you can still just get that 30
minutes on the clock then she'll figure
out how to win right but for 1500 years
you know whenever you had material the
winning formula has been trade trade
trade drag your opponent to their Doom
rookie 8 Knight takes D5 I guess he's
just weighing uh which one she likes
best personally for me trading Queens
would be uh the way I would go but if
you want to play Knight takes D5 you get
a gold membership in the park rubber's
uh uh Association even though it's
probably a completely winning move might
be the best move I wouldn't make that
move as my 39th move which is Knight
takes D5
yeah
now that's the player I want on my
Global chess League team and I was
speaking with I'm not going to give you
yeah there you go and trade the queens
and I was speaking with Arena yesterday
and she told me that yeah she's really
looking forward to playing on a team
with Magnus Carlson yeah and Bella just
basically trapped Nana's Queen into
trading yes and yeah they just reached
move 40 so I think exactly
and I kind of saw a little Grimace there
by uh Nana she's ah well I gotta trade
Queens what can I do he only has one
Pawn for the
news yeah I think she's gonna
correct a eight beat and when you drop
back with the Rook to defend B4 Knight
B5 Knight C3 and I'm with you 100 I
don't think she'll be playing much
further once that night uh well there we
have it so the remaining game uh well
the remaining game Anna our tournament
leader I just wanted to point out they
were repeating moves for it was a
repetition harika and Anna and I thought
okay makes sense that the game would
probably be drawn rather shortly
we got here and hereke said no thank you
no let's keep playing let's keep playing
H5 did she make the right decision uh
black has nothing to risk it's still
equal but
Flex position is slightly more active
right
well yeah okay uh first you know like
you you always have to look at captures
anything anything that captures checks
you know those are the things Rook takes
A4 I don't find personally attractive
because I'm thinking that in any Rook
ending where my opponent has the active
rook and I have the passive Rook not
interested so Rook takes A4 would not be
on the agenda but
kind of unhappy with this Rook on my
doorstep I might want to play the move
Rook uh to C3
or probably you would keep that Rook
wouldn't you um
with uh yeah Rook a to B5 yeah that's uh
okay so
how do I get rid of this Rook I got some
pressure that's enough now I suddenly
like how am I getting rid of this I have
to limp with that Rook on B3 oh and just
passively defendants that maybe just
move the king back to C1 and see how is
black going to actually improve well
then harika definitely made the right
choice because uh the pawn coming to H4
so okay you're saying just go ahead what
you got exactly
uh do do your worst in other words so
is H3 an issue G3
can this Rook somehow magically even
once you get there I can just defend my
Rook on E2 it should be fine
I'm not so sure not so sure feels a
little uncomfortable having a rook on G2
so and the clock times
they have 25 30 minutes yeah
time trouble is not an issue not an
issue not yet but Anna can reach the
second time travel right where it could
easily become an issue all right
interesting we'll keep an eye on that
one and Bella as uh well we've reached
the time control maybe it's time for a
break yeah not a shaking her head I
think she's going to resign very shortly
um
we've all been there we know you know
it's like we we we're not looking at the
current position we are carrying the
baggage of what we've lost essentially
you know lost luggage you know it went
missing and uh Nano is playing really a
brilliant game she had sacrificed a
piece in a very nice way found a lot of
only moves came to the precipice of
Victory and found
the one move that allowed Bella to
escape and that was surprising because
the winning move was a very obvious
obvious one it was a check exactly wow
and there you see the shake of the head
once again as Nana struggling with what
have I done what have I done I think it
was actually nimsovich
who was very famous for uh
exclaiming out loud during a tournament
game why must I lose to this idiot oh
really yes yes he was very expressive
the did you know that Alvera about
nimsovich that he shouted you know like
during a round why must I lose to it it
is a very interesting fact for you
that's quite insulting
predecessors boy they they knew what a
howler was I mean and yes he was yeah he
was good for that Patrick you know yes
sir he he was famous for oh well yes
insulting obvious opponents yes and
throwing the the Pieces away absolutely
absolutely and disgust yes I think in
today's chess on the top level we don't
have players like that they may have the
desire to do so but because now we are
everyone's on camera all the time right
I don't want such Behavior to end up on
the Internet forever exactly exactly
although I must say look it up there is
this exp madness he was playing I think
it was the world Blitz championship in
Berlin he was playing against Sasha
grishek and Magnus lost
nicely and then Magnus gets up oh yeah
oh yeah he was upset he was upset E3 E4
no resignation I think it's a good time
to take a break shall we wonderful and
we will see you on the other side of
this bridge
[Music]
the muni's premier season bursting with
comedy's romance and Magic Begins June
12th with the muni premiere of beautiful
the Carole King musical
the Epic summer continues with Disney's
Beauty and the Beast chess West Side
Story Little Shop of Horrors rent and
sister
[Music]
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game landmarked by the
world's largest chess piece sitting
outside our front door the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy including various exhibitions
monthly concerts and much more whether
you are a beginner or a professional
there is something for everyone to learn
here at the World Chess Hall of Fame
enjoy free admission to our rotating
exhibitions in our Galleries and sign up
for chess events family friendly
programming and art classes and don't
forget to stop by our award-winning gift
shop Q Boutique and Shop a wide
selection of Chess related merchandise
for more information on current exhibits
please visit worldchess hof.org
St Louis the chess capital of the United
States it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online from quirky
greeting cards to luxury chess sets
there is something for everyone at Q
Boutique enjoy a shopping experience
like no other make sure to check out Q
boutiquestl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to enjoy
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
let's see
welcome back everyone let's take a look
at our results in round five two draws
earlier today and Bella Hotel Nashville
just defeated
absolutely we I have only five only four
games that play are we have a buy by
guning just having a rest day today and
uh wow well what a score by Bella
because if you look at her line score
boy she castled short and then she cast
along and then she castled long three in
a row as uh she's on the move but she
was very fortunate winner today as Nana
was putting together what I thought was
an incredibly brilliant game until one
key moment and it all went wrong
we have one game left two of the
loneliest people in the plane holiday
our tournament leader Anna zatoski is uh
I wouldn't say defending this Rook end
game because she's not really worse but
since harika just declined
technically declined a draw for right
and I was repeating twice so harika's
the one who's pressing and trying to get
more than a draw exactly and I think
that's uh psychologically uh the the
Soviet players whenever they had a
repetition they were the ones who said
look I'm in the driver's seat so this
idea that
um harika was the one who declined the
drug maybe said that sent a message a
subtle message across the board that I'm
the one who's actually uh pushing
matters yeah
I think Anna realizes she can just stand
still and wait for black to improve
I think it's very difficult to stand
still how about Rook C3 I really want to
get rid of this Rook with the C3 but I
play Rook a to B5 and uh ah but now
replace oh you're trying to find the
Perpetual again uh repetition absolutely
I am trying to do that so if you do it
that way
what if I take and then go Rook before
right this is a king and pawn end game
that you might want to
who knows what happened what's Happening
Here I suspect it's a draw I suspect are
you sure I'm not sure
one point
so long as I don't get hit with a B4
right here yeah it could be it could be
it could be very scary to fly I think so
yeah
okay that's what you're interested okay
interesting uh I was actually trying to
get rid of this rook and uh you had
mentioned that oh well white can just
maintain the position King C2 King C1
King C2 King C1 and say I don't think
you can disturb the balance in your
favor so I'm just gonna passively wait
maybe that's the way to do it
and we have Almera in studio with a very
special guest
oh sorry welcome yes because we were
already analyzing the game with Bella so
Bella you do like it here in the studio
yeah
oh three wins in a row like how does it
feel first of all especially after the
two defeats yes
it feels really good I think today I was
lucky so
it's good sometimes to be like
well it's yes it's a very nice feeling
yes to be on the other side of course
but let's have a look first at the
opening your opening Choice here uh
Knight day6 is a very rare move did you
prepare this line or did you know it in
advance now actually I did not prepare
about this p3b shopping too I I missed
somehow that she's she's sometimes
playing
this variation so here I played Knight
A6
and
and then you decide probably it was not
a good decision
wow in your defense vesseli vanchuk
played this move it's a very interesting
move of course but maybe your position
is a bit passive yes because
um I could not develop my pieces well
after this Exchange
[Music]
and you were forced to give up the
Bishops yes
yes so
well I think that we all should admit
well we we have to admit that Nana
played this game very well and you
defend it very well you found the only
moves to stay alive in this game
so did you think about the sacrifice
first or not at all yes I was thinking
and actually I missed this idea to start
with the queen before Queen F6 otherwise
I had
um if we could start with Rook H1
probably I can play Rook E8
okay and 24 Rook E5 so
this wasn't my idea okay so here Queen
D4 is a very strong move indeed and here
G4
this is the one like probably the most
critical moment of the game Nana didn't
give the check on HH she took on D5 did
you realize immediately that the tables
were turning
yeah actually I was thinking about to
cd5 and I thought Rook c72 it was good
for me
and what did you calculate after Rook h8
King D7
okay so I went and I was thinking even
Queen G6 should be better for white
probably yeah
I don't know oh computer
well computer is very happy
you gave him the possibility to breathe
so oh yes Queen f8 is a very strong
continuation
oh yeah
so it's
it was a very beautiful gift and after
rookie seven of course black is
completely winning uh Bella it's
anyone's tournament now but tomorrow we
have a free day do you have something
planned for the free day tomorrow and
after tomorrow I have to
two three days so I don't know exactly
for now probably I will come to see some
exhibition in the afternoon and maybe
I'll then have a book
now that you mentioned that you have
another free day because zombie Corner
withdrew from the tournament how do you
feel about it
um of course it's very sad I hope she
will be fine
for the tournament it's not good but
sometimes it happens
thank you very much Bella and we'll hope
to see you in today's yes thank you once
again
our congratulations indeed three in a
row it always feels really wonderful
good luck bad luck
when is a win and uh yeah well I mean
she found rookie 8 and rookie five she
found a way of making it difficult for
her opponent and that's what it takes
one game remaining as our tournament
leader who uh Anna zatomski who's
leading the tournament by a full point
is well we think on a slightly worse
side if I can put a light slightly worse
side of a rook and pawn ending she's got
more Pond islands and maybe her King is
a little bit I don't think is that she's
heading towards second time trouble
so harita has her 31 minutes which she
gained on move 40 right and honest down
to eight minutes now and you know this
clock will keep ticking and since her
position is not that easy to defend
right time I'd actually
play a huge role in this end game no
question about it and it's always been
my experience that the space-time
Continuum is impacted whenever you're in
time trouble is like time speeds up and
it seems to accelerate when your
opponent's in time trouble slow down
and they seem to be able to play moves
with seconds on their clock but you're
absolutely right seven minutes to 31
minutes that's going to be impactful in
the near future and it also makes harika
a little bit more confident looking
across seeing your opponent having much
much less time again six minutes tarika
already had a game against Elizabeth
pets where it was a draw Rook end game
but she managed to outplay her opponent
and convert her tiny Advantage into a
win exactly so she wants to do that
again okay so let's let's put this
position under our microscopes and
suggests that black to play and win I
know it's a ridiculous suggestion of
course but how might she do that I mean
is it going to be involving uh an H Pawn
is it going to involve I don't know a
king run somewhere
probably no other idea besides h4h3
right to provoke something some kind of
a weakness in White's position right
white is kind of stuck right there's
only one weakness right now on B2 which
is very well protected indeed and it's
not enough to win so Blackness to create
a second weakness so let's try h4h3 Okay
Age oops sorry King C2 repeat some moves
for white king say one let's say why it
does nothing H3 and uh G3 could argue H2
is weak as well so but the only way to
get to it is Rook F3 Rook F1 Rook G1
Rook G2 and uh
re and you kind of said well that might
be a dead end once you get your Rook to
G2 I'll meet you with Rook to C2 so okay
well maybe black and drink the other
Rook Rook B5 rugby three and sneak in
the other okay you've done everything
yeah okay uh the other thing I had in
mind you know because you were saying
like create a second weakness uh
maximum maximum question mark is the
king maximized on
um put it anywhere maybe yeah on F4
right just because I would be
uh snug
there is a way to get to F4 a long long
way yes King is six two three four five
right now what if I just play Rook F2 oh
you have rookie three okay exactly so
imagining that the King was on F4 there
would be a potential of Rook E3 and then
maybe I really am uh doing things so uh
two winning ways
or two possible wins one is to get your
king to F4 another is to sneak your Rook
who knows how but all the way to G2 uh
otherwise Almera we can't see a way for
black to move and win four minutes and
the other possibility is to win on time
maybe the the most likely if we're going
to win the game first of all I wanted to
or underlined it both players are in
their elements uh harika just loves
these end games and Anna is in the time
travel once again right so both players
are happy yes both players
and Anna is about to make a move I try
to analyze this move with the computer
whoa because she is very short on time
and she's forcing things she's trying to
simplify the position as much as she can
in order yes to hold it to to make a
draw and I think that you shouldn't take
only five here maybe you should play
King D5
and to to keep the the square
A5 under the control if you take well
you cannot take on the six immediately
The Rook of course is hanging but if
you're like let's say Rook sees
C2 oh King D4 this I didn't even try I
was afraid that this might be very
dangerous yeah I would have asked you to
take the pawn no but I feel that this is
very dangerous let's have a look but now
it takes she takes and if I gives
check
yeah and then you will play Rook D3 yes
okay this is a very important instrument
so maybe Rook F2
here and then uh how can you defend the
spawn can you play F5 here sure so look
at four check
can give five if you protect the pound
okay
H4 yes seems very natural so what can
well you cannot protect the H4 H5 pound
anymore so how maybe you can activate
your look
rookies three Rook H5
something like this but feels quite
drawn I must say I mean I'm going to be
playing because E5 is a brilliant idea
for the way to force things uh I
understand that you know like whenever
you're it's very very hard to Define
passively and you're looking especially
when you're feeling yourself under time
trouble you're looking at forcing moves
and I think the move E5 check very very
human move oftentimes lashing out you
know it as a drawback right and I mean
in this case you know you have to
consider King D5 like aren't I helping
my opponent like up until this moment
Black's King we were actually talking
about bringing black skin therefore up
to this moment Black's King really
cannot approach right so when you make
the move E5 it's a very very
consequential move you have to imagine
King D5 in King takes D4 now now what
Almera pointed out is right here yeah
there's some split pawns and white very
fortunately seems to be winning her Pond
back by force which is what I'm confused
about the Roxy to move I know that's
engine's first choice but I thought the
idea was Rook C3
okay
but are you going to I think before I'm
playing E6 okay King takes D4 E6 I guess
I have to drop back with my Rook
excuse me uh E7 Rook E8 is the idea
I'd say I mean it's funny to see the
pawn break away for a touchdown all by
itself right I can give Rook do two
check here and go Rook D7 Rook D2
checking and I'll be picking up some of
your seventh ranked pawns okay so it's
certain moment I'm a little bit worried
about my king uh which seventh ranked
pawns should I be holding on to so I'm
not sure if I should have taken on B3
first right you you can decide that
later if you want your if you want this
setup
yeah if you want I probably do you do
okay A B and then you go down yeah and
you're hitting the guys yeah so
something like this
seven doesn't do much right rookie eight
E7 Rook E8 still I'm rounding I'm
rounding it up
I'll be down
oh two pounds or one well at the moment
you're down one but you could be down
two
well I I was thinking I'll pick up B3
and after that I'm down one pawn and
looks
yeah you might be drawing
as opposed to uh playing E7 and Rook E8
let's just see B5 Rook takes King takes
again you're kind of looking to
um
to trade as many pawns as you can and
get into you know three versus two or
what have you uh
I find it interesting that harika has
not played King D5 yet what else could
she be thinking
it's considering F takes Pawn takes and
King E6
that's easy but I think that F takes
Rook takes C5
that's easy right simplifies also
oh
yeah
I I apologize so uh F6 takes E5 Rook
takes E5 so trying to get this Rook off
the board so that either A4 or H5 bonds
exactly so it will be a a very smooth uh
trade if you will
so then and just to mention once again
tomorrow is a rest day don't tune in or
tune in 24 hours early if you like yeah
tomorrow players will have a rest day
and we'll be back Friday June 9th at the
same time yeah and I know that the World
Chess Hall of Fame is inviting all the
players have uh the curator is going to
show them the World Chess Hall of Fame
and the exhibition that is going across
the street the T.S Eliot
exhibition very very nice and I think
it's music sounds too or it sounds you
haven't seen it yet yeah nice uh E5 did
the how how does the computer light E5
Almira did the Oracle say Well done
um well he uh he says that the position
is about equal okay and I wanted to try
the move King E6 here because uh well it
has similar idea with King D5 but here
after he takes F6 uh King takes F6 I
have the same idea I can play rookie
five trade the rules of course and here
you have the pleasure of giving Rook C5
check or if taken on A4 so surprise
surprise harika played King D7 of all
the possibilities the one we didn't look
at commentators curves King to D seven
wow okay trying to keep as much material
on the board as possible King to D7
let's let's try to get the Zen of that
move
uh I'm not feeling it myself if I take
on F6 and I play D5
yeah the idea is I'm I'm welcoming
trades Rook takes D5 Rook takes and if
you go Pawn takes I want as Amara saying
uh the pleasure
of going after your H Pawn and in this
case the pawn Islands uh are kind of
convincing me that uh I've got nothing
to fear here
I would agree avoid is really fine uh
King D7 I I don't like this move uh it
it doesn't put pressure first of all it
doesn't put any pressure on White's
position but it seems to allow uh Anna
a good way of liquidating for some
exchanges yes and she started with the
E5 takes F6 capture which was yeah I
kind of gleefully jumped on that as well
and I'm again I'm expecting the right
now I've got this isolated Pawn which I
think is a potential weakness yes so I
would love and I think that this guy's a
thorn in my throat right so I re I would
really like to toss away my d-pawn for
your A-bomb now black is the one with
the pawn Islands correct yeah more Pond
Islands indeed so uh we think yes D5
very nice
plan is feeling that she
and by the way the way she just played
that move D5 that's what I'm talking
about when playing with confidence the
the the players who make the move they
hold the they look they look around did
I blunder it's almost funny but this it
sends a message across the table to your
opponent and uh see with
Authority let's put it that way I play
with authority what are you doing now
confidence must be sorted in this
tournament exactly that's what I'm
talking no hesitation that's what I'm
talking about
she knows she has equalized this
position completely right and simplified
which is critical because she only has
three minutes on the clock exactly
exactly so D5 good move
we'll probably see Pawn takes
all right and then page four maybe Rook
C5 check
okay
C5 check here I have to pause because uh
King B1 yes but I'm also considering
Rook C2
Rook C2 may I
you may
uh I take Rooks well maybe King D6 King
David six okay yummy yummy
um
yeah I don't know I don't know how to
maybe okay roxy2 and rookie three
uh had you done this before I was ready
to play King uh King D2 just attacking
The Rook on E3 I didn't want to see a
check showing up and repeat yes
precisely so
so just in this position if you uh I
wasn't eager to
um to capture either the H5 Pawn or the
A4 Pawn but rather I would have played
here
but what if I'm gonna improve the other
line slightly so after King D6 Rook
takes H5 yep instead of Rook C2 I'm
gonna go rookie three right away
E3 right away
say okay I'll fall for King D2 yes now
I'm happy I can play rookie two or
rooksy too exactly and then you do a
snack on a pond yes but here I would do
this probably this is good enough for a
draw but once again this is a a lot
simpler to to my mind I'm just going to
Shadow your Rook as soon as your Rook
goes to B3 I'll go King C2 yeah no
Advantage for black
the total
uh Amira chime in a very very nice move
D5 and we think uh Anna has equalized
completely yes Sana has equalized
completely with white yeah right I
cannot imagine a move here which would
actually lose with white so I think that
this position is quite simple to play so
the the game is headed to a draw uh yes
I actually had the question uh for you
who is our modern drone Mcenroe in chess
like the bad boy the bad boy
well I must say only because it's very
very fresh in my mind we had this U.S
Championship which Fabiano himself
called the disrespectful U.S
championships which I thought was really
really nice and it was Hans Hans Neiman
who was uh throwing around the paddies
uh but no John Mcenroe was very special
because I think he respected his
opponents but he hated the Arbiters he
was always fighting with the Arbiters
and when I think about players we don't
really get into fights with the Arbiters
no inches Arbiters don't play such a big
role right doesn't happen exactly so
yeah well I'll throw it back at who's
the bad girl
in chess
uh come on crickets in the in the
commentary come on we're in the Karen's
cup you got to take some credit for
something
the girl's a bad girl
Almira knows more playful
indifference when you were throwing me
under the bus
right
do you remember an appeals committee
with a lady
arguing as something happened in women's
dress I
I can't remember to be honest I think
you can be dishonest by the way it's
perfectly permitted well I think that no
Naga print de chevili had such a strong
character she that she always stood up
for herself and no matter what is the
situation and she was very strong-willed
and opinionated so I think that well she
is our John Mcenroe but see in the
modern era you know well we have only
good girls we only have good girls yes
that's what that's what Magnus Carlson
said about the Norwegians we we we're
very quiet we're good boys nothing ever
happens in Norway we're good boys uh
yeah but that's actually a very good
point I really don't know who the bad
girls or bad boys of uh chess might be
because again John Mcenroe was always
shouting I loved his fights with the
Arbiters we just our Arbiters are can I
be honest I don't know who that is
I don't know who we are talking about
John Macker a great tennis player okay
and he was wickedly you know you the
moment you know he hit a ball and he hit
it out and the Arbiter said out he said
are you blind you're an idiot you're
crazy look what you're doing to me I'm
an artist and you sitting there in your
chair and that was really really fun and
when he got forfeited everybody was
happy
but yeah I have another question
um who is the most subversive player of
our times well
chess voice wow wow I was thinking about
Richard Richard report
but the the word subversive is more like
has a negative connotation uh Richard I
always thought as unconventional if you
want to go in those ways or create it or
you know he's on his own he's he's in a
uh we we used to think of villa Maravich
as a person who is leading the parade by
himself
he had so much talent you know we were
all like wow who is that guy uh that's
subversive
because I I was mostly thinking if you
compare this to art that you're
challenging all the doctrines so the
dogmatic thinking the fundamentals come
in with all the creative ideas and the
openings and so that's why I was
thinking about right yes Grandmaster
reports and uh well I think he fits
perfectly right and in women's baby
Alice Lee
as being subversed again without any
negative implementation I mean that
she's challenging the current
um
how do I describe hegemony domination
right and Jesus she's changing things up
right for sure for sure and that's the
role of the new Genera the young
generations
to bring new knowledge new ideas uh to
the chess table Yeah I think
we chess players were just we're just
nice people we just we're not well these
aggressive Sportsmen what can I say what
can I say
subversive okay uh D5 on the board and
uh harika has stopped
we have a couple of moves oh I'm sorry C
takes D5 she did Rook H4 and check on C5
and Rook C2 Rook C5 pardon me and then
indeed Rook C2 because I I also stopped
here I wasn't sure myself did I want to
play with four Rooks or did I want to
play uh with two Rooks uh to play with
just two Rooks I think so too I like the
decision uh that Anna made which was
Rook C2 and I think we were looking at
King D6 as well as Rook take C2 and Rook
E3 and after King D6 yes
is there a big difference which Pawn
should white pick up A4 or H5
yes
one is a king side
what else do you want to know Captain
Obvious that's your command yes uh which
one I would pick up I probably want the
H5 Pawn because I don't think you could
ever win on The Queen side with the
pawns on a form but it's something about
you want to have an inside just in case
right exactly and by the way we do have
Rook take C2 King oops excuse me no King
D6 sorry I was
um and I here maybe it'll give you three
and we'll might see the repetition
exactly I think
Rook E3 and King D2 because I don't see
how black can continue to play for a win
here
it's extremely simplified position
exactly
um I'm still uh kind of mystified I I
seriously not a joke throughout my
career somehow I got on more appeals
committees than anybody I was never
recompensed ever for being on an appeals
committee because I never ever convened
an appeal there was never and I played
in U.S championships World Junior
Championships candidates tournaments uh
you name it and
I can't think of an appeal
like you said we're very nice people
we're very nice people Rook takes C2
King takes C2 on the board King trouble
yes exactly troubles
that's like a draw foreign
[Music]
exactly Rook B3 King C2
five here
and then pick up the pump
uh by the way yeah because we were
putting the King on D6 and a lot of the
other variations uh
that's a very good point you you may not
be afraid of uh but I'm sure you should
go for this because
oh you were playing King D3
because I I thought if you go King C3
then King D6 and black might actually
have a play here
something yeah seriously G3
looks pretty even this is the best black
right I agreed agreed yeah we're seeing
rookie 3 and Rook B3 so I think Anna is
very very happy to go into the free day
leading the tournament yeah again I want
to say by a full point and although I'm
that might not be the case Bella Bella
it's victory I think Bella's might have
been clear not clear I would have to
check this yeah yeah we have to check
the standings things are a little bit uh
thrown off kilter due to the withdrawal
of homie canero due to illness and Anna
is already looking at her score sheet
um yeah but come on Anna kingsy too
make the four-time repetition before
making the claim
um there have been cases sometimes where
you repeat three times and then your
opponent changes their mind that you
didn't claim
um
unfortunately here in St Louis we've had
tournaments the sink field cup the
Karen's cup where we've had two
withdrawals
um I was listening to the interviews of
the players sometimes it happens I think
said Bella
um
it's very rare
I I'm trying to go over my experience
I'm sure it's happened
um that we've had a withdrawal you know
due to illness
but it doesn't cost it wasn't illness
correct and this is the
Insurance Capital was due to illness
yeah not many it's it's I mean in your
experience
but yeah
and we do have a draw as
how about you Almira when you think
about your career how many round Robins
not open tournaments but how many round
Robins did you have where an opponent
withdrew
well I actually was one of those people
who you were you were uh ill yes because
I was playing the Grand Prix and then at
the end of the search I think towards
the end of the tournament yes I I was
really very sick and then I had to
withdraw from the tournament actually
one that comes to mind is uh during I
think it was World Cup but this was
coffee time so the valaranya had to
withdraw because he tested positive
exactly that was uh but again that
wasn't round robin 128 player field
I remember now Anna zatonski Anna had to
withdraw from a U.S Women's Championship
she had an appendicitis oh yeah there
must have been years ago because yeah
just well not that long ago we'll look
it up but I think it was in the let's
say last 10 years at actually Huber and
St Louis and just to remind everybody
that indeed tomorrow is a rest day but
join us on Friday as the term picks up
again and we'll have very exciting last
four rounds exactly a Sprint to the
Finish playoff if necessary would be on
its own date Tuesday June 13th as uh we
have a clear tournament leader with uh
and here we have you know having played
five rounds having played four rounds
right so we have Anna Satoshi in clear
first with three and a half points and
in clear second Bella hotanashrilli who
would have thought after starting the
tournament with two losses she's in the
clear second and that's amazing you
gotta be a believer but uh do pay
attention to the games played as opposed
to those players who have four games
played so in truth even though we're
saying that Anna as a one-point lead
she's going to be sitting she's going to
take a bite one day and Arena could
potentially win and could be potentially
tied with her right and and just to
point out when players are taking a bite
they don't get a PO they they get
nothing they get a free day yes you get
a time sharing third Elizabeth pets and
Irina Crush right and Sharon fifth three
players Alexandra questionnaire
caricatura right
and uh well uh strange tournament with
lots of twists and turns but the final
thoughts Belong To You Almera tell is
about round five
um round fight was a very interesting
one first of all I think that
Hannah well she has a tournament of her
life she's leading the tournament and
she plays confidently this is very
interesting to to notice
um well what the Resurrection on Bella's
behalf so she lost first two games then
she won three in a row and I really hope
that those two free days will not affect
you know the momentum because sometimes
players they do not like to have those
free days because they they're in shape
they're eager to play so well I hope she
will take this time well to visit a few
museums but also a lot to study a few
openings
Alexandra christinook Drew her game but
she's still very much in contention for
the very for the first place and as I
said at the beginning it's anyone's
tournament
thank you Amira and we had to do a
reshuffle because uh well Jose was a
favorite amongst us I'm the admin out
because there's two two of us two for
crash and I'm going I'm rooting for
Bella well I tell you I mean somebody's
got to be the Armageddon somebody's got
to come down hard and say this is what's
going to happen you have to forge your
own path I'm doing it
we're gonna take a day off we hope you
enjoy the rest day but we will see you
after tomorrow see you Friday
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited